une production du studio sfr nous sans
filtre le podcast son balcon avec nos
invités date site super content avec moi
d'une plante vous pouvez louer le studio
sf studio dans lequel on se trouve en ce
moment où est-ce qu'on fournit le
matériel la technique qui a toutes les
quêtes la production post production
vous en avez que vous car à venir vous
asseoir en fait puis pensez à votre
contenu seulement sur les plus d'infos à
ce sujet là un créneau sans filtre
podcast commercial gmail.com intel qui
s'était mais dans la rue si le maire de
laval maire de laval c'est un gars que
les vidéos sur youtube qui fait la
critique de culture les critiques de la
culture internet qui fait d'eux des
vidéos depuis lyon un jeune garçon fort
brillant font fort intéressé fort
cultiver c'est vraiment un super plaisir
de discuter avec lui on en parlait
justement de la pertinence ou utiles ou
l'importance de faire des critiques de
certains influenceurs de certains
agissements des fois certains le truc de
l'internet finalement on a parlé aussi
de sujets de débat de la société comme
la laïcité la loi 21 tout ce nom par
l'équité désirait vraiment prendre la
place de dany turcotte
comme vous je vois à tout le monde en
parle c'est vraiment un plaisir
s'entretenir avec lui vient ce prix
juste avant d'écouter la conversation on
va les remercier nos sponsors sans qui
rien ne serait possible
les slips le podcast est présenté par
police lit vous les connaissez commande
est souvent le podcast on les adore on
utilise nous mêmes leurs produits moi
j'adore sommet de ce petit duré toute la
nuit sous mon oreiller police lit puis
j'en suis très content clients
excessivement satisfait d'un drôle
d'histoire mme amara m'ont écrit parce
que sont chauds mieux voler son oreiller
folie slip mais on a écrit quasiment en
panique la semaine passée pour savoir
c'est un code promo pour les slips j'ai
dit écoutez le podcast c'est sylvie on
est là pour toi puis en plus polis slip
qui sont très conscients consciencieux
de l'environnement on sait que c'est un
porteur l'environnement de nos jours
policiers pour une politique de
s'ennuyer c'est ce qu'ils font en fait
ce qui vous vous essayez le matelas
pendant s'ennuie vient vous le portez ci
après sont venus vous voulez pas le
matin vient de le rechercher puis à
place de justice car t il travaille avec
des organismes au canada pour trouver
une deuxième vie à ses matelots ils
peuvent des bonnes même pardon venir
chercher votre vieux matelas pour le
disque art et d'une façon qui est plus
écologique les mettre là sont faits au
québec donc on en enlève encore une fois
l'impact environnemental du transport
est aussi dans certains quartiers pour
disques les livres à vélo donc ça
réduira évidemment l'empreinte
écologique puis c'est aussi une façon
très efficace de régler des problèmes
urbanistes on a un code promo pour
l'autre puis ma mère celle que promo qui
veut utiliser c'est le s fil s 25 pour
25 % de rabais du notez bien les dates
du 27 avril donc aujourd'hui jusqu'au 10
mai donc c'est l'occasion de maximiser
votre nuit de sommeil merci la gamme
chez police la prochaine yep sur le
podcast de cette semaine est présente
encore une fois par emma point ces
acquis et une plateforme d'assurance vie
en ligne
on sait que dans les autres stores du
sans filtre podcast y en a qui
commencent à avoir des responsabilités
que ce soit une famille ou un conjoint
ou une conjointe
advenant le club qui vous arrive quelque
chose plus on touche du bois on souhaite
évidemment pas ça à personne mais
advenant le cas que vous arrive quelque
chose vous voulez pas laisser votre
famille ou vos proches ou vous êtres
chers dans le pétrin c'est pour ça que
c'est important de se prendre une
assurance vie en fait
et m me pointer permettent de le faire
en 20 minutes en ligne selon vos besoins
et si vous ignorez que sont vos besoins
qui ont des conseillers qui vont pouvoir
vous aider dans le chat fait qu'ils vont
pouvoir vous guider latin clabaut tdma
points c'est à ce que les prix sont
super abordable et aucun examen médical
qui rit qui donc
pas de tracasser pas facile à faire et
pas trop cher et tous étaient à partir
de votre téléphone préfère ce sans
rendez-vous comme père j'ai dit ça prend
20 minutes plus tard pyjama et régler
une fois pour toutes cette question de
l'assurance vie et avoir l'esprit
tranquille
il se fait qu'à les voir sur leur
plateforme web et merci beaucoup et ma
pointure pour votre support en continu
du sans-fil podcast
[Musique]
arrête bonjour on est parti mais on est
parti on se dit que on parlait de ta pas
de casque et une aide lancé en fait
juste avant que ça c'est qu'une patte
cassée ce mois-ci moon et le maire de
laval youtuber que ma nature culturelle
fait que ouais je présentais le cela est
parfait mais ce cas grec
enfin les intros si ce même voilà c'est
la foi qui me plaît parce que j'écoute
vos podcasts des fois je t'ai ce que
j'allais devoir être le putsch et qui
fait bizarrement ça faisait partie des
taties le quinoa grille de nos pauvres
et oui c'est parti mon podcast fait voir
charlotte à tous les auditeurs sont
fidji la marque à québec
deuxièmement si c'est bon je vois
plusieurs pots de 4 je le dis à personne
mais challenge jamais fait que moi je
pensais que tu disais ça parce que tu
étais la seule podcast au féminin ouais
ouais c'est sûr c'est sûr qu'en faisant
la meilleur podcast vous avez peut-être
le meilleur les gars mais moi j aime
mieux dans leur peau qu'à ce qu'ils
disaient que si l'homme c'est le
meilleur podcast sur internet animé par
nous animé par nice et de cannes 0-1
s'attendre à dio et veulent tout cela
annonce et a annoncé ta podcast dans un
vidéo qui s'appelait ya trop de podcasts
hockey
explique moi le raisonnement parce
qu'effectivement il y en a tabarnak des
botteurs carapace et encore moins les
comme le lait le podcast games et si
j'en rêvais sens comme un genre tu le
vois partout comme moi je connais le
plus de monde possible qu'il fasse ça va
devenir le meilleur comme game le site
du film un gadget je peux je recommence
à guy qui j'ai dit en outre au québec
pour codes des blues sur le monde qui a
la dira encore une autre crise de
podcasts jusqu'à mener une autre pas de
casse mais cette fois ci c'est la
meilleure fait quoi si dans le fond
j'avais recommencé fait vers quand même
ma chaîne youtube a commencé à
fonctionner pour changer le format de
vidéo que je sais pas si tu t'es un peu
la même chose john coates et comme sait
pas trop comment c'est comme mon vrai
ton de voix quand je parle dans la vie
quand tchèque mais vidéo jamais
avec le g10 titre je faisais fait divers
comme au printemps demain 19h30 moi seul
qui parle d'une nouvelle la semaine puis
j'ai tout le temps dit que j'allais le
ramener avec un invité puis voulait le
faire le printemps dernier que v2
witches c'était un bon dieu parce que je
pense que je vais te faire la peau de
cas ce que je fais la n va ni penser
j'en prends parce que dans dernières
années deux camps même goût et si ces
créateurs de contenus 3d se fait dans le
fond quoi qu'en ce cas ci c'est
quelqu'un qui voulait lancer avec un
invité
quelle était la motivation de d'abord
invité parce que tu es vidéo c'était toi
tout seul et qui amenait quand même quel
est ton point de vue sur plein plein de
sujets fait pourquoi tu t'es dit le jeu
avant une conversation est ce que c'est
ça la force et quand tu fais des vidéos
de soldes d'opinion ou est-ce que tu
l'aies monde seuls dessus du
contre-arguments seul site app
perspectives en fait la plus important
site de contrôle qu'est ce que le monde
voit au complet complet quand et justin
youtube en six mois je pense que je
pense pas ma vision fait que le monde te
connaissent pas c'est tout ce contrôle
qu'est ce qu'ils connaissent de toi fais
quand tu es en situation avec un invité
les six plus et c'est plus libres qui
comprend il va avoir du challenge lors
des discussions de ce savoir qu'est-ce
que je pense qu'à une chose que j'ai eu
que j'ai pas pareil que j'ai décidé de
pas parler mais que j'ai jamais eu la
chance quand je décide de faire vidéo
sont un sujet petit si tout le temps je
sais que l'ong food trentaine c'est le
sais ce que je veux c'est que j'ai un
côté moi je fais comme je m en sers tout
le temps à ce genre si ce que j'écoute
si ce que j'aimerais que le monde écoute
de moi je préfère la marpa
cette vidéo est toujours de tahiti une
podcasting ça nous écoute en ph et 10
ans
c'est exact
si nous on se colle sans filtre studio
parce que tout le monde tout le temps
des filtres fait que nous les enlève
jusqu'à -10 rection j'ai failli perdre
s'il est vu comme de première main le ti
l'ascension du podcast au québec tu nous
qu'incombe start est le nôtre un gpo
l'été 2010 était 2018 ouais il y en
avait pas tant que les écouter des
podcasts dans le monde de l'humour
monsieur des podcasts des gens
s'assoient puis engeance d'ici peu
l'humour raconte des anecdotes c'est
beaucoup ce mes mais comme ce ppi le sas
a fait le cinquième en trois ans puis
des puits mais qu'on a lancé le truc
qu'on se disait l'idée une zone serait
de vouloir lutter un petit peu contre la
culture de la nouvelle rapide fidèles du
contenu chokling beit l'insee fille
parce que c'était il y avait que ça en
fait qu'ils circulaient sur le web seppi
puis des entrevues à 15 minutes avec 35
minutes de pub à la télé ou la radio dit
dans le fond puis nous aurons se dédiant
on veut comme démocratiser cette forme
le long way ce que les gens peuvent
venir parler puis comme de fait d'un
puits c'est pas juste lié à nous le met
la commercialiser aussi le pied
incapable de rendre ce de faire l'argent
avec ceux de rendre son efficacité
limitée au départ jeudi au départ les
studios step up the super agent sa
cuisine son bac
on arrivé j'étais avec mes micro les
camés gros montel sonate est on arrivé
une heure et demie avant montesson
démonter ce type i c'est elle on voit
qu'on fait si tu as de l'argent avec ce
factice a apporté street day one qui ont
fait du cash avec un jour faire un
podcast parce qu'on a envie de
rencontrer du monde
avoir une bonne discussion pitié c'est y
mettons les invités les invités qui
venait cela podcast la majorité du temps
c'était le premier pas casque réside
dans ma peau de karstologie dit comme
maintenant je me retrouve un interview
du monde en les sources publiques au
québec qui cherche les entrevues qui ont
déjà fait je me retrouve à devoir
écouter votre équipe à chaque fois le
monde s'entraidait de l'ubs s'est jamais
pu parler de tout l'orient et ayez aussi
longtemps que parler d'un tel sujet qui
me passionne
qu'ils montrent aussi découvrez du monde
qui connaissaient mais d'une façon
qu'ils n'avaient jamais connu même menti
même les hommes qui écumait sa vie sur
les réseaux sociaux
ses premiers pas de casque on a fait
perdre mon commentaire qui visait j'ai
jamais vu lisandro 6 millions cc by le
film hanté par le fantôme et c'était
voir la discussion générale at il pas
tiens de bosses tu peux tu peux fait
qu'est pendant une vidéo montée de john
comme tu disais le monde qui écoute des
vidéos john scott il c'est pas comme ça
que tu parles en vitesse et une botte
en fait c'est que tu choisis comme tu
disais c'est ce que dit xavier pendant
une heure et demie deux étaient toutes
étoiles comme je pourrais je pourrais
aller au lounge enregistreur vidéo puis
parler d'un sujet à un autre
gouvernement pendant longtemps le ch
cette capacité là mais moi si c'est la
discussion ça fait en sorte que
justement lisons ne se laisse jamais
vous demandera pas de casse
on le voit partout dans le monde que ce
sera fait ce genre fixé juste
l'évolution naturelle de comme le la
forme de celle plus seemingly ce genre
comme si juste du monde qui parle depuis
que mon père ainsi que veulent ils
après c'est allé explorer comme dans ce
médium là comment il ya plein d'autres
sorts de potes car mon bus comme ça vous
allez john dans spéciaux comme bien si
c'est un monde est finie le podcast que
le monde aime s'écouter niche et c'est
comme wasquehal crever de reggie avant
j'écoutais beaucoup de musique qu'ils
écoutent juste des podcasts ou la radio
où j'en fais
belle la radio line wenger fait que ces
gens si j'ai perdu l'espace de la
musique juste parce que je jouais tout
le temps écouter quelque chose que les
gens pensent que c'est souvent quelque
chose qui revient dieu sait que les gens
ont l'impression est assez le monde font
la vaisselle bio l'impression d'entendre
des gens parler juste à côté si c'est
exact ça littéralement des gens qui
parlent même et c'est vrai que ça c'est
vrai que c'est cesser ça fait partie de
l'expérience humaine
on dirait c'est sûr c'est plus humain
tout je parlais je parlais de contenus
clique pas tout à fait quand même
puis c'est que c'est quand même deux
choses vraiment différente d'impôt kaspi
des vidéoclips bail sur des sujets aussi
ce qui est ce que tu crois que le monde
qui ont découvert mais ton avec la laine
vidéo et tu parlais des p o beaudoin
puis puis l'histoire avec le sait pas
parler review ce que je fais a construit
tout s'est vraiment relier c'est comme
un signe de nouvelles en tant que tel il
ya plein des annonceurs d'une vague de
gens qui paraissent force publique que
tu sais pas qui parle de c'est juste de
quoi qui parle beaucoup de gens se
demandent qui m'ont dit que voir à
travers deux choses il et j'ai parlé
mais à travers ce qu'est ce que moi je
fais je peux décemment dans la nouvelle
j'essaie de faire des jokes du monde
s'attachent à la façon que je parle de
certaines situations
puis c'est pour ça que moi je vais à lui
pas du tout la performance de mathias
comparé à 12h12 pas la même chose le
monde qui ont décidé d'accueillir
d'écouter mon podcast s'arrêter à ce
qu'est ce que j'ai fait en tant que
c'est un autre game complètement d'un
espace public et comme j'ai pas du tout
bâti ce personnage est autour de ma
personne
qu'est ce que c'est juste autour de mes
vidéos moi je trouve que c'est vraiment
c'est plus sexy sans trop tôt fait que
jean les cliques beit intacte elle sait
que je pense pas que le club ait pour
attirer les gens à voir qu'est ce qu'il
faut pas se cacher que toutes les plus
grosses médiatique package les choses
pour que les gens cliquent de subsister
qui fait si juste tu veux que le monde
écoute qu'est ce que tu as à dire dans
une monde tout le monde crie tout le
monde du bruit partout puis pour stand à
l'autre faut que tu comprennes qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui attire les jokers
moi j'aime occupation double je pourrais
parler d'occupation double sur des
scores des amis pendant trois heures et
je vais aller faire un vidéo de moi qui
parle rodez bio tout le monde
c'est pas un peu long pour aller dans
les dérives de gamins qu'on interprète
pour dijon mâcon les extras police du
caire maxi juste drôle pour moi dans le
fond ça déprime c'est un autre affaire
s'il a réussi à prendre leur propre mais
le contenu clic bates et comme je trouve
que si on le donne souvent eu tout bord
quand toutes les formes des médias font
ce cross de bourges fait que si c'est
comme moi je fais je fais des communes
et qui attire l'oeil déjà pour qu'ils
écoutent ce que j'ai à dire
j'sais pas si c'est parce qu'ils
accueillent entretien de jardins jardin
discute amis dans ton connu versus en
fait dans le contenant versus le contenu
utile parce que quand tu clé quand
mettons que je clique sur une vidéo où
est-ce que tu traite justement un sujet
de l'heure où tu prêtes d'influenceurs
aussi que le livre de cassandre bouchard
mais donc vraiment c'est un sujet ultra
clic bates qui répond à tous les codes
de youtube mais qui a tout de même
rejoint six amis ou ses deux coupes des
deux chaînes de kiki qui favorise le
reçoit plomb sur les influenceurs
bashing mettons le connecteur on va te
trouve qu'on va y aller sans filtre il
ya combien de chaînes comme intérêt ici
chariot magazine ok il ya moi ici
charlie et du monde qui s'est fait que
peu d'influencé bashing c'est une
industrie qui strive sigean le ont le
droit de parler d'eux on commente requis
il ya beau du bashing c'est un mot
vraiment à connotation négative que je
peux voir écouter actually que je lui
dis maintenant sur la vidéo du vivat
cassandra maison c'est sale c'est
largement à l'asie ce jeune s'est
directement logements allaient dans le
sens où tu utilise des codes qui sont
connus parce que oui il ya on peut on
peut nommer trois pistes charlier au
québec sauf que ce principe là existent
ou audois exacte et un code qui est tout
à fait reconnu sûr que quand tu cliques
sur le contenu ces lacunes dichotomie
entre le fond plat forme parce que on
parce qu'on dirait que le conducteur
offre fit comme pas dans ce que dans ce
moulin je pense tu comprends je pense
que moi j'aime vraiment que tu étais
vidéo ce que je trouve que tu amènes
merci une perspective qui est différente
qui nuance et qui réfléchit mais dans un
format
et qui répond à des codes qu'ils sont
rares mais bon c'est celle là c'est ce
qu'ils font ces personnes je sais pas ce
que j'ai juste mis ce que lui au début
parce que ce point comptoir de juin
continuent à utiliser l'expression
influenceurs bashing parce que le cadet
est sûre ce mais est ce que c'est juste
la tv si tu t'es fait machine pour toi
c'est la crise et l'espace public
je pense que ce moule parce que la digue
a tenu aussi qui se passe avec youtube
puis donner ton d'opinion sur youtube
versus denis tour des pneus dans
l'espace public sexy personnifie tout le
monde pense que si moi personnellement
aussi non à m'emmener oui je le fais à
titre personnel parce que personne
n'écoute
mais à un moment donné si genre si une
opinion dans l'espace public comme l'iso
jo fixe le monde vont sentir plus libre
dimanche marque alice l'internet j'ai
grandi avec ce à juste top chez de genre
tués lors des troubles nerveux quand
j'étais jeune je sais que tu manques
sont pas d'accord avec tout et de rien
colleen fait plaisir c'était pas
d'accord avec moi j'étais encore plus
contente à écouter aux yeux du monde que
je revienne mais vidéo pour les jo mais
des fois je fais des points qui
comprennent pas tant mais le monde qui
écrivent des longs arguments qui ont
compris a cru qu est ce que je vous le
dis il ya une grosse culture va mais
quand même du tout que devant vous des
défauts des gens qui ont des longues
discussions sur pointes des piges comme
si ce que je veux pourquoi chercher leur
plein fouet sur bakchich tout juste que
c'est la critique c'est comme je pense
que si j'ai vu que c'est à ce milieu où
ouais bon on fait comme si tu critiquais
des gens oui mais c'est la face et que
c'est un peu ça on dirait parce que
pilote je réfléchis vraiment avoir
disputé des raisons que je voulais je
voulais c'est seal avec soul et je
trouve que mettons là ils étaient
sérieux de la télé c'est une critique de
quelque chose qui est qui et à
l'extérieur de des artisans qu'ils font
c'est un c'est quelque chose de complet
tandis que d'utiliser parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est la
personnification ça ceci comme si moi tu
fais un vidéo sur le livre de cassandre
horschamp puis là encore c'est ce sens
je suis d'accord
c'est une critique d'un les jeux
distribués par des critiques de livres
même tu peux prendre des égards mais pop
la paix en faire la critique faisant
plaisir d'écouter puis je sais qu est ce
que tu vas dire sûrement du fait que
c'est une critique c'est la même
principe que c'est juste la télé qui
comprend de trouver alors que d'utiliser
mettons le nom de quelqu'un qui fait une
part ce que ressent tant que faux
challenger les influences on en parlais
tantôt fou challenge et les influenceurs
sur leur plateau par sur partout sur
cette base c'est important de faire sur
de changer les influenceurs sauf que moi
je me questionne sur la limite de quelle
façon on aimerait que ça s'excuse je
pense qu'il se serait sur une discussion
plus large
comment concrètement sur des gens comme
si c'est ça la fac-ci que vu que ses
dc10 personnalité c'est des gens qui
font prolifique mans vous connaissez si
j'en ai personnellement j'en ils font du
club c'est l'une des belles filles ont
des bandeaux comme lyon des beaux
contres d'été d'advertising normalement
cee la compagnie de marketing ce qu'on
veut on sauve l'argent mais ça coûte
tellement plus cher faire une pub anti
virus la compagnie production depuis les
influenceurs fois comme fait qu'on prend
sur la prémisse que si j'enlève fondu
cup sur les yeux des gens si ce qui leur
rapporte que nous au canada si très
contrôlé les yeux des gens côté
traditionnel certifier toutes les ondes
qui sont détruites des licences et si si
vraiment piqué sur qu'est-ce qui se rend
aux yeux des gens sauf dans ce milieu
qui nous vaut qui émergent où est ce que
ces gens le font prolifique mans
tellement de choses dans la culture par
monts et par mots mais qu'est ce qui
apporte concrètement la culture il y en
a pas beaucoup qui en a il y en a qui le
font je pense tout bas et j'ai dit comme
et du monde qui font un produit culturel
du ciron pour moi c'est un produit
culturel alicia me fait ses fils font
qu'on y apporte même juste sur essaiera
m'enlève du tout il ya de quoi que je
vois un value acheter mes yeux du monde
que nos offenses qui était alors dit on
fait une émission télé réalité - il a
fait ce sont 10 30e le fait qu'on peut
m'utiliser comme exemple les hommes et
non mais tu ignores il ya un produit a
créé le monde peuvent du genre te fait
combien de 335 6 735 podcast en mieux
devant sa surface caennaise pour sécher
les mécanismes d'euros déjà fait qu'un
il ya du monde car il après odéon à
110000 son sillage et influences puis
boum ça rentre en saroubi
c'est comme c'est beau challenge et
c'est qui ces gens lyon je fais tu
shootes est vexé comme mouche juste et
on va dire ce qu'on veut c'est gens là
ces gens le font tout le club qui
veulent jory
ils nous mentent pas quelle contrée qui
vont accepter ou powell avait dit c'est
quoi manger
j'ai appelé j'ai senti j'ai passé mon
message a suspendu tant d internet c
comme je sais que mouvant les exhaustive
en tout temps existé je le poker est
d'exister j'aime ça
le haut moi je suis mettons entre les
deux déchirures semences et de pousser
mais c'est que d'un côté oui
effectivement puisse y mettons en
influençant ax prom vois quelque chose
qui est quelquefois king pas de bon sens
outil qui s'est carrément des
informations ou quelques aurait une
influence que tu dis je peux pas croire
que des ados qui qui qui check subtil
aussi si on tombe en demandant dans la
morale mais aucun disco complètement
incohérent le titre teams et ont une
influence aussi très critiqué mais ton
pour des pubs et des soumettant le
comprendre les critiques jeudi à manille
les critiques légitimes
puis de l'autre côté en ce moment les
réseaux sociaux que je peux te le dire
on sent comme une espèce de dagne ici de
plus en plus polarisé le monde sait
qu'ils vivent de plus en plus d' insulte
j'ai l'impression qu'ils peut-être des
fois cette critique le en venir ce genre
de climat étrange en tout temps cette
observation comme à l'écrit ce soit pour
avoir intégré consomment beaucoup
d'internet depuis comme bientôt genre 10
15 ans je pense qu'elle a un terme être
tout le temps été un peu comme ça par ma
perspective premier jeu de plus en plus
précises agencés comme la montée du
black light magic pad comme moi sûrs et
sains et puis j'entends parler de
racisme justice genre 6 abobo dudit des
grosses manifestations avant même que
tout se passant du bien comme dans à
tahiti à l'interné tyran non la pandémie
si fucked up qui monde a envie de sortir
dehors ce sera construit à l'endroit
dans l'axé se parler mais de djibouti au
réseau social c'est juste toutefois
mills a devancé speed sur la d re a
comme ça va trop vite il ya trop de
contenir trop de jacques disent trop
dure trois heures qui dit quoi c'est
parfait mais il est temps car de pignan
jusqu'à maintenant
jamais à ces seules affaires basques
yushan si jamais ce que l'opinion qui
veut changer quel autre myopie le à
amman il faut se dire oui l'internet et
randy cola raisonnement mais si oui
est-ce qu'ils sont les discussions par
exemple 22 mètres c'est en dessous des
publications des plus gros mais dieu
qu'on a au québec jean si le l'endroit
le plus toxique sur internet ils savent
qu'il instrumentalis puis après on va
les bâches et sur 2 you to work qui font
du haut et cette promo geslin poppy
berruti venir ici à 12 semaines au maire
de laval et de ce secteur un trou de cul
de nos pilotes à faire chez moi des fois
on dit comme réfléchissez et pignons pl
il dit des photos classiques y
réfléchissant fois la vidéo santé un
ouais j'ai fait tout ça peut les repérer
tout est allé trop loin
1 l'année dernière parce que dans le
fond il y avait fait une vidéo de 36
minutes sur youtube qui est encore mieux
c'est peut-être mon avis je sais pas où
est ce que c'était quand même un peu
évidente il classique brickdown de
youtube au genre comme en mai afin vont
publier des chiffres et si je sens plus
le monde s'intéresse à moi mais numbers
a foncé ce qui voulait dire non ce n'est
pas un chiffre sur internet où tout me
puis il était quand j'ai mené j'ai pas
de budget pour faire une vidéo puis il y
avait des gros challenge des gens qu'il
ya tellement de gens qui veulent qui est
juste trois personnes qu'ils écoutent
phillips fils vidéo puis et déjà mais
les gens il ya trente mille vidéos jeux
vidéo peluches équipe au comptant de
combien de gens a dit le cheikh mbacké
il a fait se dit celle qui a pas de
ressusciter après le mode d senti simoni
season pour les influenceurs biélorussie
a fait une comme un enfer de gens -
instagram se disent annonce pendant
trois semaines john non-stop portrait
entre qui fait un vidéo ce qui jetait
commis au global c'est peut-être pour
ceux que le monde s'intéresse plus à toi
parce que tu as complètement
commercialisé ton contenu puis qu'est-ce
que tu rapportes aux gens qui suivent en
tracteur le la vraie question c'est
mounir préparer son sac à l'elysée
visiblement c'était la question qui
semblait sur moi pis et puis c'est là
que pose la question qui est sous
tendant à toute séduction
c'est pourquoi c'est parce qu'elle est
moche mais j'ai comme andrée on dirait
pipe attaquer peut-être que c'est juste
parce que mâche pas ses parents zidane
ainsi dans le web qui tous et je me dis
le monde nos finalistes et je dois y y
si les abonnés décide de se désabonner
si les abonnés à des tirs de rester à
bonne et inversement qu'à comparer
tantôt du monde qui vont à rodez si le
monde décide de suivre ces gens là on
est qui réellement pour questionner la
pertinence puis la légitimité de ces
gens leur paie de leurs actions ces
méchas que wes et ce depuis jeudi dans
le vidéo mais c'est juste que moi le
pourquoi c'est juste que si ce qui je
veux voir une chose comment ce qui nous
intéressait le plus dans la culture
c'est pas la culture ces paroles et de
la culture du concret si tout juste
brigands du taxi ce qui m'a aidé c'est
juste de la tv 6,6 à exécuter mon
chouchou préféré quand savoir tv comme
c'est ce qui me fascine si les
discussions sur comment les mécanismes
ont peur à toutes les sphères la société
je m'applique beaucoup à la culture web
à ce que je perds dans le web si ce qui
drive du trafic mais si on me donnait
une chronique à la radio par ray
peut-être des influenceurs une faute
roos mais nous ne faut trop - ya plein
d'autres choses qui se passe dans le
monde que si j'avais un micro je
déciderai d'apt qui montrera si je suis
c'est une vitrine je comprends moi j'en
parle dans ce soir le surtout à ce
moment là ça faisait comme un an et demi
je faisais des vidéos comme j'ai juste
qui lui sera des plus gros tubes québec
viennent brique d'or noir se comme je
vais aller donner monte qu'à dessus bas
c'est ce que je fais aujourd'hui
comprends qu'on ait pas de malentendu
conclu mal à 100% 100 % puis mais ça
m'amène à un autre question pour toi
parce qu'avec la avec la qualité du
contenu était capable de faire puis ce
désir là de vouloir observer la culture
observé l'extérieur pourquoi tu fais pas
ça
et surtout c'est pourquoi c'est pas ce
n'est pas que ce soit ce que tâchent ans
il monte maintenant les collègues la
critique du livre de cassandre bouchard
qui tu te pris la peine de lire d'en
faire une critique sur doute vraiment
légitime le tissu orange étudiant en
littérature puis je comprends c'est que
quoi que tu y arrives tu le fais quand
même bien dit je me dis pourquoi ce sera
même du trafic mais maintenant tout
comme tel de la tribune tous les gens
qui te suivent qui suivent
potentiellement qui ont un pourcentage
qui trie pour ce genre d'affaires le
mais moi je me dis que j'en utilise la
qualité du contenu était capable de
faire sur une tribune que tout pour
faire ce que tu dis là tu es jeune tu
dis tu dis on menace si on me donne une
tribune mais je le fais relations usa 68
vidéo smashait new way en 12 570 je
pourrais pas faire un pourcentage enlève
ou des auditions groupe 5 de ma chaîne
faite sur des influences son
attractivité g de l'embrayage te parle
culture web en général mais en général
je pense que je parle de caisse que je
veux parler je ne les met pas à mal et
puis à travers tout cela est parsemé de
mon public dans l'élection juste que je
viens d'eros de critiques et l'irak afin
de il ya un vide outre 15 minutes de moi
qui parle des élections qui ya comme une
balance jamais voulu m'enfermer fait que
chan peu que je fais je parle de tout ce
que je veux parler jeté du sympathique
limite d'un sujet dans le fond non je
pense que je me limite à ce sujet je
pense juste que pour le pourquoi à la
base broussy c1
le jammu le tibet aussi divertissant ça
fait partie du lot ça fait parti tout
seul sur internet il faut pas dit si
vous êtes susceptible youtube américain
vous êtes monde qu'est ce qu'on est en
sursis quand même si je ce job il faut
amener moyennes limites anjar qui laisse
à tous types d'armes au déni comme avant
même que les serrures que je vais aller
se retourner pour panini france heures
si imparfaite de quatre fois comme qui
georges me lis pas je me limite mais
jusqu'à est-ce que ses ouailles titre
que masquer la maintenance est rendue et
que moi je fasse de quoi est ce que ces
nouveaux titres que moi je met le linge
pas là-dessus ce site mais ceux ci c'est
le plus maintenant mais genre j'aime le
diamant à la base puis y'a pas une chose
qui peut être quatre étudiants mode
coach aux déchetteries
fouad est resté dans le milieu web qui
peuvent représenter dans l'immédiat en
tant qu elle fait que s'ils avaient une
entité médiatique qui couvrirait c'est
comme une fois avons investi même le
j'aimerais savoir donner mon 100 fois je
comprends pas pourquoi mon
questionnement il ya du monde qu'ils
font mais comme il dirige martineau
fucking dit que les woks au wac trois
fois par semaine dans son estime jonna
lee personne fait proust chaud c'est
juste vu que c'est sur le web fait
qu'ancrer avait quand même en tribunes
au québec genre d'affaires c'est qu'un
foyer en utilisant aussi l'école
justement c'est certain que c'est déclic
des danseurs y est je pense que vu que
ces web c'est nouveau c'est plus facile
de faire un lieu pourquoi tu prends du
temps dans la journée pour faire ce
messi s'était emballée d'un média se
seraient joints aux tchèques j'ai lu ce
article par semaine soit géré us à
partir de semaine au monde et nos
équipes dans l'espace public a deux fils
value c'est juste un épi non plus grande
du fait de 160 vidéo sur des sujets
variés où ce qui est mon opinion vaut
être pris en sueur pomme tous les sujets
que j'ai décidé de parler ceci est un
brin de justement diversifier les vidéos
puis si justement tu observes vidéo que
je fais ce que j'ai jamais avant neigera
par rapport aux des plus cette année je
trouve que les mieux structurées que
l'année passée mais je faisais vraiment
f2 odf de ports audio hd audio vidéo
parodie ce que ça donnait du à chaque
semaine mais que jamais drogué maigre
mais c'était pour venir la question de
prendre pour la réaction si je pense pas
que tu aies judy sommes toutes tes
vidéos team et ont justement ta critique
durée de quatre ans à bouchard téthys
ccpo un procès complet lançant ce qui
était somme toute nuance et tu dis petit
tu t'attaques pas personnellement quand
on embauche heures type de bâti jeux du
back home comme comme une critique assez
négative c'est quoi un spectacle
lendemain tout le journal
c'est quelqu'un qui est bien à ton
spectacle la peau est mise à l'essai
qu'il coûte me gally faut indiquer que
moi je trouve pourquoi personne chaque
page tournée
un jour tomber dans ce genre tombé dans
des articles qui avait écrit sur moi
puis c'est juste créé le doute jetez
rien que j'ai eu après hot est allé
observer tout ce qui a été dit sur toi
ton nom sur google cherche les les
articles sont sortis avec ton nom d'un
général sur main sur martin de qu'ils
ont eu pire que moi ptac et leur
entourage les ont protégés de tulle
mettez moi rien surtout qu'ils étaient
si pire que ça même si juste croft qui
constituait qu'un article du goût du
moche de ma gueule sic m
il traite de plein d'affaires petite
fille quand même je n'ai même pas été
moi même mais si socke est ce que tu
trouves que c'est j'ai eu la réponse
rapide à dire au québec la critique on
voit tout temps à prendre personnel ou
de l'apprendre culturellement puis mais
est ce que tu penses au québec en haïti
parce que en france non en france j'ai
redit aux états unis et la france pour
ses pires ayew qui les commentaires ici
huge comme j'ai le feeling qui on a ça
c'est vraiment juste mon impression là
j'ai le feeling que au québec on n'est
pas assez beaucoup fait que les
célébrités puis les artistes sont
vraiment proches de de la culture et de
la société puis de ce genre de critiques
nautique
je prends un exemple ici mettons ici tu
écris un tweet à guy a lepage il ya 90%
de chances qu'ils l'exercent
il vaut pas de répondre sauf que c'est
ce qu'ils veulent lire quand même je le
vois des foires et pas on a du monde 10
de leurs 15 tweets en dessous et qui
remplira ses soeurs exemple ils rendent
à des barreaux surtout ça n'a pas de
sens c'est fini puis lui qui comme une
des plus grandes célébrités au québec
type le mettons que tu vas en france les
plus grandes célébrités il s'est
peut-être même pas aux autres qui gère
le réseau sociaux ils doivent pas tomber
dans d'en lire les journaux lendemain de
leur pièce ou à des routes ici c'est
qu'on est vraiment proche dessus tout un
spectacle ici une pièce de théâtre
mettons au québec tu donnes tout ton âme
la basse sur que le lendemain tu vas
tomber dans le journal je veux lire sur
elop la critique mais j'ai l'impression
qu'ailleurs dans la veine et peut-être
les critiques qui le fais je connais
peut-être la personne se croiser dans
des événements pi ca 7 millions de
personnes le savent a vite le comment ça
commençait à tâtons personnellement
c'est moins cher dos des métaux
quelqu'un qui sort de l'eau island le
qu'ils ont fait à alex auld ces
personnes là il sort de là il ya trop
d'argent qui a été créé à leur sujet il
ya trop de trucs peuvent pas de paul
prendre personnel il ya trop d'avancé ce
qui l'est moins mais tant de sordo des
wilayas deux personnes qui ont écrit à
ton sujet qui traite de menteur au genre
de manipulateur ok ok mais quand site
effectue un travail personnel parce que
tu es que là dessus mais c'est vraiment
un feeling que j'ai tiré puis au québec
personne qui est assez gros pour ne pas
être collée sur la kinect riquiqui aussi
plus de temps en france qui est vraiment
plus une culture du débutant au salève
le temps à la maison points soit apte et
puis ça c'est à nîmes etc tandis qu'ici
on est moins lâche cas dont les plus
saillants vraiment on aime le silence ça
vaut bien inquiet si tu as tout dit
richard b yep souris sourit cette chute
et non non on dispose que tout est
arrivé de quoi que l'on dise n'est pas
en ligue 2
je pense que tout va bien on aime on
aime la chicane à c'est quand même pour
que des des articles je te mets plus
cliquez ici c'est quelque chose mais
mais c'est dans l'espace public le team
mettons que je thomas guillot est un
petit peu trop avec un évident d'être on
en parle une fois le
le rôle prend pas le thé est ce que tu
penses que vu que j'ai commencé à quand
j'ai commencé la discussion moi j'ai
commencé à dire des noms ça vous admire
les à +6 nomi qu'est ce que vous pensiez
parce que j'écoute beaucoup votre
podcast
bin oui c'est sans fil mais il ya au
québec on aime pas beaucoup ont dit boy
ce qui suppose que vous savez tout
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya ça pis on
n'aime pas mais là bas je pense que
c'est juste parce que l'exemple qu'on a
donnée mais non juste je pense que
j'observe c'est juste qu'il était
certain que je me dis que ce n'est pas
nécessaire a dit c'est vous coincez
sujet mettant je veux pas mettre de
l'huile sur le feu je promets de l'huile
sur le feu qu'un feu provoque tout et
tout je veux et tu fais jusqu'à juste a
marre je te sais pas qu'est-ce que plus
juste quelle tendance à attendre demande
ce qu'on prenne tout le monde parce que
des faits comme tout candidat mme
séquence est pas nécessaire
moi je comprends pas l'idée de le faire
il ya tellement des débats que je vois
c'est que justement les syriens qui ont
cependant la question genre si propre au
québec france et que si c'est difficile
de dire dans les commentaires
je pense que je crains c'est que si je
trouve que mes points sont bien ils sont
bien reçus puis justement j'ai cédé à
lille plus nuancée possible du sud dans
un climat où est ce que le contexte
politique est divisée moi je capable
d'aller sur internet puis dire you chuck
qui ya fait son médecin- choc
il ya dit qu'à la faire plein de choses
dans son premier élections puis comparé
après le président américain il ya fait
beaucoup des choses qui a dit qu'à la
fois tu peux mais mr fois que puis je
dire cette phrase veut dans les maisons
au québec
oui savent même pas pourquoi qu'on a des
manises ethiopie fock chock dee dee
fonctionne tellement ce vaste riou pêche
capables d'avoir cette nuance le
démontre en fait comme si ce qui a je
pense du monde voir mon contenu fait que
je sais que moi je me sens pas une place
puisque ici genre oui je dis je parle le
genre désert de site off le commentaire
mais j'ai un pote des résistances
contractuels je trouve ça normal qu'ils
aient cassandre eux elle aime pas ma
critique du livre ici de la foire comme
nommé comme gilles duceppe ce j'ai dit
que c'était pas j'ai avec moi ça va
faire mal peu importe même le ceci genre
cepeo beaudry je t'aime à cette personne
que je pense
quand j'ai fait mon premier 2 sur le
taxi 2 c'est quand même en vidéo c'était
parmi plein de choses mais mon vieux
stand a beaucoup hésité pas à mettre en
avant ce qui fait que je pense qu'il ya
eu un sentiment mêlé jamais diplôme un
an après j'ai fait un vidéo sur lui mais
l'on sait écrire
on s'est parlé après vidéo puis j'ai dit
et on te fait une affaire dans le taxi
qui a transcendé imaginaire
collectivement des grandes la tête
d'affiche des influenceurs cancon dits
influents surtout aux beaux draps on
parle plus du tout de toi bien falloir
je sais me chante bien mais je pense
qu'il ya quatre firmes terme montego
dans une discussion de mardi m je
pourrais faire des jokes il fait qu'il y
aurait du marché les ch'ti taxi wolfang
chi tabarnak vivait comme moi étaient
raison j'ai répondu prendre le taxi ça
car c'est là que sa rencontre mais c'est
ça mais je pense jusqu'à on a besoin de
plus de dialogue je pense vite il risque
c'est justement notamment souvent déjà
des débats dans l'espace public y ait
deux enquêtes de la loire qui quelque
chose l'autre répond mais c'est comme
deux monologues chacun de leurs bords
qui des fois j'avais plus de personnes
ne se parlent et disent comprendre est
tellement parce qu'on s'estime aussi sur
beaucoup sur la manière qu'on veut
parler fait comment passer une
discussion complète à dire qu'ils aient
pas qu'on peut plus rien dire dans
l'espace public
quand une pause deux hôtels à + 2 qui
sera dit qu'est ce que le mot à dire
qu'ils disent pas moi c'est tout quand
j'entends ce point le ça me fait rire
parce que comme moi je dis c'est à dire
dans les dix dernières années je fais
julie 168 fois puis l'agent piqueur au
roi mais quand tu parles pas de sujet on
te fait chier mais quand on en parle
pourquoi est ce que titrait il ya du
monde qui visiteront dance paradise
internet genre je suis vraiment dans mon
temps je suis tellement détachées massy
tellement genre si c'est un aspect
tellement conceptuelle des enfants mais
pour moi je le vois vraiment de plus ou
perspective extérieur job tout si ces
mouvements des comment l'intérêt du
moment si ce qui m'intéresse le plus ce
à quoi le monde pense genre qu'est ce
qui passe à travers et leur taille du
monde parce que moi je parlais des
caisses qui repose pour sa part est
intéressant
l'ex tout de même que j'observe internet
fait le saut quantique en dix ans
internet life s'est rendue mais sinon le
monde live
ils sont neuf à cause du coup vite qu
est-ce qu il normal ça de vrai c'est
comme ces facteurs mais je pense aussi
de cépie le jeu pour rentrer dans le
genre des jeux parce que le jeu va être
les classiques jambes que tu vu sont
charles de l'est moins mais c'est la
page qui quelque chose dans la manière
de casser mais cela fonctionne qui
traverse ce pays
optez même pas le fait que ces genres
l'algorithme qui ne possède juste le
fait qu est qu un tempo team et on le
dit si on discute de trucs on augmente
un peu mais je t'apprécie j'ai vraiment
qu'ils ne subissent pas de vie pas très
d'ici on s'est quand même plaisir et
tiff sauf que si mettons nous au thd en
podcast on disait en lui est faite elle
vidéo puis je pas la copie t on se
répondent même sans se parler face à
face ça qui rit ça nous éloigne tout
nous approcher d'accord plus qu'un pic
est pas pour de vrais c comme crise
devait finalement un style et on n'est
pas si un désaccord que ceux où j'espère
ce dénuement
ça c'est une bonne chose que tu es parce
que ceux-ci plein de monde qui sont même
soit honnête que dans mousse pour ce que
je dis dramatise beaucoup l'internet
c'est comme un père pour trouver suis
gentil comme tout ce que moi je peu
stressé avec allait dire pas dire le
forfait d'andy greene a quand même hâte
à peut-être raison mainstage comme il
n'y a pas ce niveau dramatisation pour
moi que je pense que les gens devraient
opérer avec ses baskets
si nous qui décide si quoi que des
secouristes sur internet si cette marche
sur des oeufs alors que tu marches les
unes tout le monde vont juste attendre
que tu marches sur ce qu'on fait ça fait
le métier au basket ben oui le monde qui
ça crisse d'études une méthode du
politically correct mais surtout ceux
qui disent tous mais qui team et on jeta
ma dîme et ont été pris par caisse du
mot au québec.le qui disent tous qu'ils
veulent
hiller fanbase c'est encore 10 ans quand
il était tout content ne le dis à
personne de forger pitié mais des fois
il ya un clip qui sorte que ma religion
kretschmann pendant deux jours mais
pendant deux jours si ces facteurs deux
jours peu après ce
13 27 l'internet 6 et fougueuse des fois
ci c'est vrai mais si c'est comme si un
enfant si sochaux dans les morts c'est
comme ça intéresse le monde live ci
dessus le traite de même si c'est que
depuis la fin de son show dans la mode
j'ai trouvé drôle c'est quand est ce
qu'on ne savait pas tous des jeux qui
était de même l'internet moi je sais
c'est que vous n'avez pas entendu être
originaux d'une voix qu'est ce qu'ils
sont capables de faire ce qu'elle a dit
versus le monde qui font attention
kystique est qui qui qui qui qui
s'intéressent au chemin aux mouvements
sociaux ceux qui essayent de faire la
bonne chose
ils sont deux fois plus critiqué le
manque sacralise complètement petit
foulard afin que leur public des places
us si c'est un dur des fois une défense
fait on se fait des enfants des
commentaires puis c'est quand même et
l'or parce qu'on vient de dire le 6 le
tiers de ce qu'est mettons un mac dias
j'écoute le coup de main pour que mon
fils aime quelque chose plus rare en
spectacle sur québécois qui rien
finalement
mais quand c'est quoi ces conneries qui
sait que c'est pas grave que ce soit
quelque chose maintenant mais c'est ce
qu'on fait là que parce que quand tu dis
que l'internet n'en sais rien si rien
t'es l'intérieur l'intérieur l'internet
n'existe pas les six tellement un gros
termes de mémoire mais ça existe ici
gilles dostaler fait que cacher la voie
aux jo
oui ça existe pas en tant que tel dans
ta vraie vie sains mais ça a existé si
dualité si ce à tout âge
c'est pisser comme 6 10 tours
l'admettons de marine gens que qui dit
scott facteurs de ce qu'est ce qu'elle a
dit stephen objectivement moi je faisais
j'aurais si elle avait subitement drive
à elle est ce que tu ne dirait pas son
nom
la vierge à la retenue et s'est excusé
aussi d'avoir discours de factum ou s'il
n'est pas d'accord c'est ce que
maintenant calaudi de quoi de fucked up
à béton 80% fucked up
souvent on va entre les lignes dirait
qu'elle a dit quoi à 120% facto de
conversys aussi toutes les corrections
cd ouvrir qu'avec une fois les à travers
le monde
l'internet ça donne à voir à tout le
monde c'est pas ça la vraie voix du
monde 80 je suis un chiffre vraiment
grotesque
la majorité du monde qui checke de chute
sur internet ont jamais commente une
vidéo de leur maintenance est démesuré
comme si good pitié quoique le camp même
qui dit que c'est faux col avons su que
c'est la pire personne d'avoir 10 e
c'est peut-être ce qui va attirer le
monde à aller écouter qu'est ce que le
diacre lis avec moi je trouve que
l'internet faut pas s'arrêter à du mont
de fourche yeux du monde que live dans
l'eau chaude à ce moment là c'est ce que
ça a chuté chez eux si ce qui arrive tu
sais même pas si cette personne non moi
je te dise pour ce que j'en - je trouve
faiblesse j'ai grandi là dedans a juste
tenu du monde que je connais pas du tout
petit incapable de voir à travers le nom
c'est une capacité qui est pas tout le
monde qui est ce que tu te dois recevoir
des commentaires aussi des négatifs du
monde franchit tout semble avoir les
capacités de dirigeant cela est choquant
c'est important mais steam et on met
mais dany turcotte qui reçoit plein de
messages
moi j'ai envie d'asseoir et dany pu
faire comme you and i ça fait 15 ans tu
fais sur le québec tarde stx correct
alors c'est que j'ai piqué ce qui est
beau avec dany turcotte c'est que moi en
tant que téléspectateur du show à voir
nice confronté à voir l'autre le frère
alex you on s'ennuie daniela 40 que
c'est pas facile à la face des gueux la
fin de la première intervention d'alex
de genre il regarde fait comme il se
retourne
c'est clairement dit le genre ok sans
trêve eu lieu je voyais cas par le passé
n'est donc pas qu'un partage on faisait
la doxa vous la fin de l'émission
avec l'ajout de jeu peu plate comme moi
n'ont perdu apatow son repli à hélène
boudreau bien équipée patof le mémoire
est voix écrit ce mal et je vois les
livres jouets du ceop la semaine
prochaine ces jeux sa cause qui il
restait une minute trente au chauffe
c'est comme un clic qu'est-ce qu'on
parle plus tu vois guillet comme un peu
tellement pas habitué des d'astres cette
situation le qui est comme vraiment
stressé plus qu'irrationnelle ennemi à
qui on parle de quoi plaire à alex qui
me séparent les deux facettes joke le
puits est juste dire qu'ils font le tri
moi quand je vais être le jaffa dieu
quand tu restes
c'est la seule façon d'avoir qui attend
pas de casse dalle est à tout le monde
en parle c'est ça me rate on est à la
tombola par la semaine d'après qui
restent sont pas de casse les gars de la
poche bleus sont à l'atome on a par
semaine c'est une histoire humaine et mr
ils n'ont pas mis ce but un job moi je
les spams demande à ton monde d'hier
aussi la dalle fait j'ai demandé à mon
monde de commenter un poste de radio can
pièce addition pour mounir pilet le
pauvre est si beau mot qui frôle ans
parce que j'ai pas eu de non on me dit
on fait pas d'édition à ce moment que j
-cr producteur et moi pas plus j'ai fais
ok plafond des auditions à tchoyi fait
que j'ai bon bah oui ils peuvent aller
oms qui ont grimpé tout dire mais c'est
ça aussi mission à fait raison d'eux ou
peut-être je sais pas si à dimanche
c'est peut-être la dernière dix ans
jusqu'à la tour c'est un fake je sais
pas mouais je peux faire la dernière
ronde ce service au québec c'est juste
que le jeu relance parce que j'ai
commencé ici jeter comme you see chu en
direct la radio quand je me dis que de
quoi pas de world tiennent sur le bon
mais je veux juste colonnes le fait que
la culture c'est de l'est marc genre
joëlle ferrand direct je vais laisser un
est silence genre de l'intéressé qui
n'existe jamais devenir je suis
quelqu'un qui aime soigner la peau et
italie après king et moi parce que les
pétales
si si il y avait juste nappe sur le fait
qu il y avait moins d'artistes et quand
itunes à 2 sari fait du sens à tout le
monde en parle ap le qui pensent à tout
le monde en parle c'est juste comme
yoann ne serait pas comme si tu avais eu
un kit de 22 ans qui commence à faire du
bien d'être immortalisé ce moment de sa
carrière le jeu c'est comme partout dans
le monde les artistes qui bloque aux
thèses comme awake in zelenka qu'elle
avait 14 ans le chantage charlevoix
comme on ne documente hiller jeunesse de
saisie qu'on est international mais qui
tu n'as de nogent il ya un reportage de
vries québec john tiner sont seuls et
1,6 au québec qu'est ce qui est mon cas
je pense parce qu'ils black qui parce
qu'il fait de la bastille black
principalement qui est juste à toutes
les blagues parce qu'il y avait dans la
culture urbaine urbaine c'est un mot
gentrifié pour dire non aux états unis
fait mais ce que j'en fais ya ces
anglophones ou est-ce que tu adores bobo
l'entremise dans l'ouest d'aller dans
les quartiers dans les universités
anglophones
si ce qui est beau dans les clubs que
vous pourrez enfin king igloofest qui
remplit toutes si le belmont chaque
semaine depuis tellement genre
undergroung tellement c'est un mouvement
flamme de grateloup seulement mon feu ya
créé en son genre en soi ya plein de
gens qui font de la musique comme
kitchen à deux partout dans le monde
c'est pas juste genre on ne le lui dire
et puis toute personne ya beaucoup de
gentilles nine point d'annoncer un des
meilleurs albums moi j'appelle le maire
album montréal et basse que dans ce
temps là moi je découvrir montréal
j'écoutais juste ce qui est une à deux
en gage sur le camaïeu j'ai passé ma vie
à la vague en commençant à l'huile à mon
galaxy gio fait que tu t'en ailles un
point dans un pick-up y est c'est juste
il ya créé un son qui tellement jean
ping est populaire chez pas même si je
veux avec jeridi parce qu'il est black
jack vont faire comment mener 6 voies de
la race partout mais je trouve c'est
quand même un gros facteur parce qu'ils
sont avait visé pas vraiment parce qu'il
est black je veux tu sois je fais un
voeu de voir en direct le monde hfpa
qu'est ce que j'ai dit parce qu'il ya
des plus douces yeux blancs aussi et
chaque c'est un peu d'où ce qui a peu
douces l'habitant d'un projet exigeant
tintin tintin il fait de la tête basse
c'est juste la culture dans laquelle il
oeuvre depuis acquis pis ccx intéressant
même s'il vaut mieux s'intéresser à qui
tu as deux catcheurs de ce cas partout
mais c'est aussi le cas quand ils
passent pas par l'espèce de chemins
d'été mettons là la presse un article
sur nous à pile tu vois tu ltée
tu vois radio c'est comme une espèce de
deux chemins classiques ne se séparer
d'un nouveau chemin alternatif qui
n'existait pas avant
oui je sais c'est comme ça sera en pole
parlement qui était joseph guillot il y
avait jamais entendu parler de kitona
des avants qui tout le monde l'art celle
pour qui l'invitent programme métissé ce
petit jeu c'est espèce de m'insulter
béton embaucher d'autres exemples chez
les amis viennent saper le manager steve
poste connaît ceux des puits et autres
et comme jo d indy peuple dans le fond
le cyclisme a rebondi sa salle un succès
dans la salle mongols sont en tournée
aux states en europe en asie c'est avec
kiki qui tournaient donc avec all time
low ya pas deux
un rapport le classement way avec mais
on la machine du chili non non ils
gardent voyons aussi gore mais ça c'est
son album
ils y ont donc fait une accolade à des
coups de moins de filles ont joué à
terrace bay ont fait la première de
détail ou non non non mais ils y ont
collaboré avec qui sont allés à le
festival atteint le sait c'est au total
est son festival en tout cas bref être
bref les autres un succès international
mongol ce que ces web footsie des
millions de vieux os sur leur truc
mais vu qu'ils ont tout fait ce genre
sans relationniste de presse cavaliers
communiquer at-elle journal piété
l'émission pétel six pièces et si tout
fait sur le web
c'est comme son sont invisibles des
méthodes rationnelles qui sont ici c'est
ça change tout genre j'ai une vision
très cynique de se mettant à mon début
du tout comme mais chaque ça veut juste
y aller naturellement puis c'est le
monde qui vont prendre des postes qui
ont de l'ampleur vont avour serrador le
fait que je suis dit c'est que beaucoup
de choses qui postulera d'or du monde
sont à leur bull pi que c'est pas de
leur faute si ça se passe ils savent
juste pas que ça existe en ce moment que
ça s'est fait comme souvent moi c'est
pour ça que georges mais parle souvent à
interpréter les choses comme la mauvaise
possible estimant la culture mais ils
savent sûrement entendu parler tellement
de l'année s'amender connectés type et
j'ai l'impression que ça a toujours été
un peu seul c'est là que la culture
génétiquement le grunge et arriverez le
tir quand nous revenons à arriver genre
s'était pas c'est devenu mainstream
parce qu'elle a menées n'ont pas eu le
choix de 28 min rim parce qu'ils
remplissaient des hostilités diamnche
sauf que je mets tout petit rapport par
le bouche à oreille puis à faire des
shows donnés déplacer en deux grandes
parties de faire connaître autant
fallait que le monde par des cassettes
le type step up radio la radio c'est
meanstream cats étaient connus mais pas
du mouvement immo ce n'est qu'un gros
les vols qui avait banni moyens qu'ils
ont fait un gros clip et en veillant
pousser sa radio pile mais ça c'est la
machine la t 130 avait dedans que c'est
dégueu du québec zecs extension ils sont
revenus au kinzo des guides script des
gens de ski mais qui reviennent au
québec qu'ils font c'est comme les codes
s'époumone aller faire des choix avec
réactiver le piège c'est vraiment pays
puis de moi vu que je la tenais qui
décoche investis qui sait même pas s'ils
étaient populaires aux states will
rogers com center il ya dix top tic qui
tue l'un d'eux pour ce qu'il est une
discussion il ya un ressentiment qui se
fait quand t'es pas accueilli par la
culture de wes que tu viens tu sais
juste que tu regardes plus jamais
derrière phelps qui tua domaine ya envie
de donner des entrevues à 6,6 place l'ex
tout ce que je trouve ça drôle que
décrit 26 tweets en mai ont été évités
pour faire une autre vie d'une semaine
ouais après qu'il eut trois nominations
le fait qu il ya un épisode ressentiment
pied de blues à l'extérieur puis revenir
redonner à la communauté mais je vois ce
que tu es comme si le pop n avait pu y
est juste blois puisque puis comme ytrac
comme kitsch je sois comme bail mais je
peux comprendre site et une carrière
internationale qui était en apprennent
des des acteurs aussi des acteurs
québécois extrêmement internationale qui
reviennent pas l'expulser savez ceux qui
excusent et ouais l'être humain oui
c'est à laval ses plus gros succès au
monde offre d'accord là par exemple en
ce moment mais s'il verse
je lui c'est démesuré sa part avancé des
mesures et ses 79 millions d'heures
écoutez en 2000 foyers excusé c'est quoi
qui fait tout genre principalement ces
jours ci à gage leur gran theft auto
france oui j'en ris il est membre des x
men du genre cent dix mille personnes
qu'ils écoutent a regardé une vidéo sur
youtube ayant parlé de moi et puis
commencer suis moins cher des
populations 2006 je le groupe twitch
cote chuter comme il ya du monde veut
juste trouver quelqu'un avec qui passer
du temps à nous comme moi limite ça
m'intéresse plus de stu mais toucher les
cheveux ça va il été fait comme j'ai pas
envie de passer mon temps tu me les gens
juste mais on peut même pas sortir fait
peut-être au basket
michael m'a demandé mais c'est un check
parlons-en parce que bien parlons pas
nécessairement dmytruk mais je voulais
savoir tout et tu mets ton temps je le
tue 100 % à créer du contenu à être sur
le web c'est comment tu t'es quand même
temps tu le payes ton appart
je paie moins en partie dans folle avait
une autre je travaillais au sirop sa
clientèle puis à cause là que vit notre
jeu peut dire exactement ce que je
travaille même genre neutre endroit ça a
été vraiment rue par la revue de ligue
la sphère convention dans laquelle fait
qu exacerber sa clientèle d'un salon de
massage érotique
je suis en septembre dans cet homme est
à pied parce que justement je t'ai passé
ou d'ancienneté puis deux en même temps
que ça s'arrête du tout que ça
fonctionnait bien là en disant cette
histoire puis au 10 enfants payants sur
ma chaîne fait comme je vis de youtube
est né et j'ai lancé mon podcast juste
de youtou janvier que c'est comme si
c'était une boule youtube live à court
moyen terme si j'ai pas avec adsense
m'avait 400 seulement mon petit chien
depuis que l'argent que j'ai fait en
travaillant carré de l'argent jean avec
6 e qui paye mon loyer live puis a causé
une solution à court moyen terme faut
que j ai quelque chose qui s'en vient
bientôt pour que ça fonctionne les plans
de jeu ce fut tout pendant ce temps j ai
fait la voix ça quand même temps je
pense que bientôt j'ai volé j'ai avons
une opportunité qui va faire sur ce que
je pour travailler dans l'inconscience
de faire confiance aux je suis
commerçante en chalosse autant à qu'est
ce que j'ai fait à l'année passée mais
toi même date
jetez pas le mail je trouve que jean
j'ai vraiment dû logiquement simsek
avenue où se joue une fois qu'il soit et
ce vide où il faut qu'une fois ce vide
au fait que c'est juste comme yémen qui
fait jean georges suis prêt j'ai envie
puis chaque ça va s'en venir je le
disais le manifeste josh afu je fais
quelques poches que des tokio même quand
j'ai pris de gainsbourg de juste arrêter
de fare ute oublier fera pas de castets
comme bien ça ça fonctionne pas long
terme et court moyen terme le plus juste
et c'est mon mode de vie que tellement
proches fine bouche avec un yes is alive
qui ont parlé par le team est une
manière qui mettons encore pour faire de
la vraie argent québec faut que tous
sont un peu dans les médias
traditionnels
ps que c'est quelque chose que toute la
france est quelque chose que je peux
faire ce que tu vois quand je commente
comment tu vas le faire ben là je me
pratique chez nous je pense ça serait
bon en fait le mot ça fait une couple de
semaines là dessus j'en écris genre
comme d'autres par semaine puis tu es et
tu les fais tu n'en je les fais je fais
je les écris ce genre à prendre et que
jamais écrire
quand tu fais de la radio des magistrats
seafood soumettre qu'est ce que tu fais
avoir quand j'ai appris ce jeudi
jusqu'au mot qu'il faut que sois capable
d'écrire qu'est ce que je veux mais tu
es tu capable
est ce que tu es limmat ont peut-être
qu'avec des phares à voir des gens
logique des écoles devraient faire seule
c'est le next next du coach fait cela je
fais mes vidéos ce que je peux et je
veux les écrivent le soumettent
est-ce que tu pas se laisser faire ça en
radio les écrire le soumettre faire que
moi ça va être à peu près ça me this is
joe qui vient de reprendre et fo qui
faisait pousser son idée c'est trop
risqué mais je ne sais pas je dis
seulement que je te quitte mêlant je
pense que je vais réussir à chelsea fc
j'ai eu une porte j'ai ma propre parti
sur un plateau idéologie t il dans une
websérie à télé-québec s'appelle la
reine système d'élection ce jusqu'au
foie qui affecte des gens qui
travaillent à la cuisse gauche peut le
trouver un job mais oui je vais lui
c'est la piste voici sait encore qui
connaît mes vidéos à ce que beaucoup de
gens dans le youtube qui son valet
combien y que de mes vidéos - juste tout
le temps été chanceux par kiki de mes
vidéos
la fille qui a écrit la série a et qui
la série avec moi en fait pour être
l'animateur des barreaux et m'a juste
dit m sur 1,10 logique rhinois
psychiatrique
j'ai fais pas d'addition port et la
digue au crédit sur ayem dit bylsma king
on commence à monter dans ces pays en
déroute qui était mal à l'avancé et
criminel cadre i also known as se lit
très très très fort il y avait
flaubert qui écrit à madame bovary
il fait il y avait une pièce dans sa
chance dans sa maison qui s'appelait il
appelle son crash on le sait comme
expression du crachoir de flaubert
puis il yal elle pour lire à voix haute
les textes mais les criées fait que
jamais qui commence et madame bovary de
flaubert madame bovary fille dans ce
temps là j'étais à la requête de ce
morceau il n'y a pas de meilleurs débuts
qui est madame bovary de talloires
jambhoji aux galeries la chambre et
madame bovary et à leurs actions
j'ai acheté la bovary j'ai commencé j'ai
pas si tu vois un monarque qui sema
ouais bah oui maison faite à l'adversité
genre de programme que c'était un homme
qui sait juste que les développements
pourra en parler à celle des discussions
d'attitude qui on la pensait deux
semaines a subi métier je comprends que
ces règles mais un personnage des filles
comme qui a été comme gaby ou au roman
le chevalier pierre au romantisme sur
tech les leçons de la mort est
complètement dit stationné commun et
réalistes les méthodes puis et stylisé
ce but elle est associée tellement elle
demande que tu connais la nature c'est
vrai parce que j'ai laissé la pauvre et
c'est vrai c'est bon c'est fort c'est
vrai c'est bon c'est bon ça a marqué sa
marque et beaucoup aux commandes d'un
magazine en gros on joue à minecraft
qu'est ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'y
connais documentaire sur la deuxième
guerre mondiale
c'est qu'ils aient j'ai un gros budget
tout le temps aimé l'histoire mais j'ai
réalisé que comme l'histoire qui m'a
intéressé quand j'étais ado si je la
regrette live la majorité je me rappelle
pas du tout je demandai je crois pour
acquis que je me rappelle de toutes ces
choses ne me le juge
genre tu vois une autre je pensais
j'avais parié avec 10 pris par les
allemands ont vaguement mais comme j
avais pas quittés rester là 4-1 puis
quand j'ai vu de quoi là dessus je veux
un clip de deux minutes gens là dessus
ça me juste pété un but qui sont restés
là quatre ans plus tard je tombe sur un
document donne une heure et demie
strueth ou ben jawad de parisiens qui
était le qui parlait de l'occupation
mélangé avec du foot et l'occupation
ça me dirait clore cette guerre me
fascine tellement que je vais c'est
débile le cdb revendre les les résultats
impôts les résultats mais l'ailé ce qui
se passait durant la guerre c'était pas
mal de tellement tellement longtemps au
rythme des saisons en plus c'est comme
si le fait qu'on doit réussi dans six
mois les gars en normandie qui sont
restés les mêmes pendant d hiver complet
le tir et ajuste un étrange chine même
âge les gammes des roms m dos tourné
long day couvre-feu à 8h forme de shin
corp des rues bondées corps lisse tout
mène ces petits joueurs siemens à être a
duré pendant ce n'est pas six ans la
deuxième guerre mondiale
sans sa semaine pense à ceux de six ans
mais nous est ce qu'elle est et quatre
ans en france où il ya des nazis qui se
promène dans la rue pitt empêche de
sortir de chez vous mais c'est faux
toute cette espèce de monter les gens
dans la france dû comme du monde qui
font un des partis politiques mais ils
sont jusqu'à mieux collaborer tellement
facteur vient d'adopter comme moi et
attaquer la france nation qu'on a bâtie
à travaillerait des guillotines pourquoi
pas non c'est faux que des bâches et
comme quoi on peut détruit paris puis le
jeter cameron est lui-même paris qui dit
famille l'agent mon grand père était un
collabo et les allemands le titre
alexandre jardin le ticket qu'il quitte
en hauteur qui son dernier livre c'est
sur son grand père justement inclus par
la deuxième guerre mondiale et que la
brique les amap c'est comme la la honte
de la famille
et l'espèce d'affaires de justement ça
se passe pendant tellement longtemps
puis les lignes allemandes sont
tellement loin que t'as aucune idée que
ce qui se passe dans les lignes en oncle
des deux côtés y arrive le lycée viette
les alliés arrive clé commencé à
découvrir gens ils se découvrent des
cars qui est faux king de gens qui sont
morts il lui porte aux américains les
américains il faut commencer la
propagande si pauvre l'examen juste la
découverte qu'est ce qui venait de se
passer
joyau découvert le premier et ont
découvert les américains pour leur
premier camp de concentration
ils ont juste d'arrêter ils ont appelé
le haut commandant jean yves naouri est
rentré italie puis à fait inquiets
maintenant prenez moi toutes les caméras
qu'on ne dans toutes les feuilles king
bataillon pis tout le monde écrivait
tout ce que vous voyez pas ce que un
jour le du monde qui vont questionner
que ça c'est vraiment poste c'est quand
les gens voient des choses à travers des
perspectives historiques ça me fascine
tellement gens qui a concentré d'enfants
de moi qui marque l'histoire au complet
de nous le jeu et qu'on parle de tout ça
5 octobre tél jarnac
parce que on va en parler dans dix ans
tancé ses fautes
aujourd'hui à genève c'est comme si les
gens 6 6 1 6 labrosse traduite et une
des pires tragédies sinon la plus grosse
de l'histoire d'humanité mais pas mal ça
se passe et c'était comme le monde fait
pas croire que c'était juste aider rim
of science aaas plus donc ça lui
semblait fort les allemands section
avant de contrôler comme aline nouvelles
fonctions jeu comporte pas de
championnat c'est juste les mécanismes
de nouvelles que lyon ils étaient riches
auraient pas été le premier à faire ce
parti de toute façon je sais mais
admettons là qu'on enlève tout les
médias comme on les connaît puis la
technologie qu'on a aujourd'hui le
quelqu'un qui arrive ici qu'ils y
aillent veulent le même pendant les
arrêts en ce moment en italie
les hôpitaux sont remplis le monde sont
pas capables le monde meurt lethier
entre le manège hôpitaux parce qu'on n'a
pas assez de stars pour ne pas
d'équipement si on n'a pas les images de
ce on croit pas aux seuls six étaient
factices et germaine en royans et si tu
vois maintenant guéries
déclare in usa au canada et jeunesse le
parlement débat de trois mois qu'un pays
et même si on n'a pas de marge on sait
pas et disent que c'est quand
d'adaptation sociale parce que green à
devenir chinois aussi des musulmans
c'est que charlotte à tout musulman
c'est ramadan qui commence mais chacun
commence aujourd'hui
c'est ce que j'ai dit paul fort
aujourd'hui puis par mes parents mes
parents sont d'accord parce que je fais
tu tapes votre podcast pas prêt je fais
comment le vaccin pouvait pas bordeaux
en ce moment j'ai encore mangé jaune
mais j'ai pas je peux lui faudrait qu'il
faut bien du tout tu le fais tu le fais
tout le temps je lis je n'ai pas fait
quand je vous photo cg je m'entraînais
tout laisse à attendre le ramadan c'est
lé type je m'entraînais tout l'été ce
soir et aiderait mais je le fais puis si
bonne soit une pratique religieuse pour
moi je pratique culturelle genre comme
ça ça le ramadan un tweet en fait partie
d'eux comme lors de ma famille c'est un
espèce de cycle des saisons stick de ton
année scolaire
si c'est tabou ce genre d'avis je viens
quand maintenant ça fait partie du jeu
rendez dans l'année c'est le ramadhan
aussi culturel pour moi ce que je peux
souhaiter je veux qu'on parle de ça
parce que tu dis que quand tu joues au
foot tu le faisais pas j'imagine que
c'est vraiment propre à chaque famille
parce que il y avait un gars quand je
mangeais c'est un des meilleurs nageurs
au pays où 200 kroll il s'appelait
assène abdel-khalik puis lui il allait
faire les olympiques sauf que les essais
olympiques sont tombés pendant ce temps
le puits lui il n'est pas question qu'il
fasse pour je touchais pour la coupe du
monde deux siècles fait qu'il s'est pas
qualifié manier fait des contre
performances il y avait zéro énergie et
est nul à chier comparativement se
creusent habituellement mais lui c'était
dans sa famille s'étaient donné la
sienne non négociable il probablement
que c'était son choix qui me ravit c'est
fou c'est une scène et puis j'ai 23 ans
je dis je quitte 10e avant que pas assez
j'ai demandé par six pays mais j'aurais
pu faire sans leur demander mais c'est
justement là les lèches élèves si c'est
que moi la région musulmane est vraiment
pis les religions en général c'est
vraiment basé sur genre sans toi mal
vite au fait ce genre
si ce mécanisme qui n'est pas demander
aux hôpitaux neufs le plus de la
religion parce que si on adhère au
concept d'un dieu sait que je sais que
c'est une bonne personne sipa name crise
et que jean font davantage pendant des
[Rires]
mois j'ai été chanceux bachand ceci
juste - genre carew je marque ce n'est
pas ce que je voulais jouer au foot
nyrstar je m'entraînais six fois se
mêlent l'été gens je pouvais juste papa
bordeaux jamais mais je te dire du monde
pour la coupe du monde de soccer pour
l'équipe du costa d'algérie où il ya eu
marre et puis quelle équipe mais il y
avait plein jour qu'il fabrique avait
décidé de faire le ramadan pour moi ce
jeu était jusqu à pisser comme limité au
maroc après je pars et je sais que cette
coupe du monde pourront trouver ce
binôme puis moi je trouve mais cgg de la
mesure même avec toutes les religions
vraiment cool
j'ai vraiment la misère avec ça parce
que parce que justement pour ces choses
là qui sont irrationnels
ces décisions là qui sont complètement
décalé de l'expérience mais on dirait le
tisseur puis
mince c'est certain mais c'est ce qui
c'est le concept de religion concept de
spiritueux ces choses différentes et les
religions organisées qui sont têtus et
vie par l'homme qui comprend mecs tu
veut adhérer au concept ailleurs
beginning c'est juste ce vote du monde
aussi juste si juste bien plus
satisfaisant comme conclusion dans ce
débat d'urgence comprend qu'il y aura un
duel si tu veux pour le port est content
c'est juste bien plus apaisant puis mes
dadas derrière comment tu dois croire
seul de ces justes jetez moi je pense
même plus depuis que j'ai réglisse et
confie dit quand j'étais à 17 18 ans je
fais de l'esquissé du mossad est une
institution on dirait que ça pervertit
tout le truc le dit andré quelqu'un
d'immense ça n'empêche de ça ça reste
cette idée young lee qu'est ce qui est
écrit dans le livre que l'homme
ils étaient parfaites ce comprend
pikinois la cci texte jorioz l'homme
l'interprète si c'est tellement flou
c'est mettons dans mon qu est ce qu
elles réduisaient lé roman j'avais un
autre course que je disait l'abbé petit
peu rhdp on l'utilisait pour parler en
son petit qui se raconte justement à
quel point ce pacte leur passage
c'est très contradictoires puis un livre
apprend à l'opti en réalité je dis cet
ouvrage le prométhée écrit par un
collectif de personnes à des moments de
l'histoire différentes ça a été ramassé
en sensibilité que ça a été changé les
traductions saah sah sa notoriété city
c'est vraiment excessivement dur à part
sortir juste avec tout ça donne pas de
réponse à faire le gros des bottes et
moi qui élevé dans la religion musulmane
qui vaut mon parent pendant que je fais
ok tu es musulman
ducrocq coran gilles c'est ce genre cet
angle fouet
ouais je crois du en plus je dis ok mais
ce que tu crois aux dinosaures pied
juste fait comme y est puis comment mais
c'est pas super que réputés comme moi
mais c'est juste avec si chacun a
d'ailleurs ce de la façon qui vérifie ça
devrait aller
ça devrait
jamais être dogmatique une vérité
factuelle la société qui peut à retirer
certains messages certaines réflexions
certaines valeurs mais du moment que tu
te dis ok donc actuellement
historiquement la terre à 5200
comblement notifié il ya des freins de
certaines religions qui sont le texte
c'est plus cela donne envie parce que
vaille pages plus loin quelque chose
contre eux discuter aux états unis les
émissions ici le débat qui s'est acquis
mais at-elle versées et ils se disent
oui mais cette longtemps déjà déjà
qu'ils sont juste fortune athéistes qui
sont juste qu'il soit neutre juste sur
la tisza troupe de nouvelles jantes
individus tous qui reçoit des collines
de montrer le juge injuste steen et sur
l'existence de dieu je suis tombé sur un
doux de qui s'appelle réseau à celle en
qui je pense que c'est un swing iranien
je me souviens plus que thomas lui été
je pense que grandi en étant chrétien
puis il sait convertir le jour musulmans
parce qu'ils trouvent que c'est la
religion qui lui parlent le plus petit
trot la plus belle qui trouvaient que
l'espèce de code de valeurs qui dépayse
histoire c'est ce qu'il parlait mais
c'est un tout un expert de la bible
jésus théologie de halki théologue qui
écrit ja qui délivre sur le jésus
historique taa puissant together toutes
les infos qu'on peut avoir sur qui
pourra être ce goal à y écrire l'espèce
de de semis fiction entre côté du moins
d'essayer de voir qui sera le plus jeune
érotique le sort et l'on considère
excellence concept assez fort
intéressante il ya des vidéos du nord de
lui sur youtube et qui s'est déjà deux
chroniques explique son livre si le
froid king intéressant
de voir à quel point je dis que c'est
historique moi je peux comprendre
pourquoi pas ce qu'il faut c'est qu'à
cette époque le des prophètes comme
jésus les navettes toutes les ceintures
et puis je sais que tu connais beaucoup
plus cette région du monde que moi même
et on sait dans les pays musulmans du
moyen-orient il y en a encore jugé le
chef taliban haqqani a mis depuis lui
étaient amis et que madame qui à chaque
semaine a cédé par la vierge marie
pilotes à passer à travers la vierge
marie puis dans son appart comme 300
personnes qui joue un petit actif déjà
des profits en existe encore mais il y
en a encore mais en fait elle était est
et chrétienne mais au liban
c'est comme c'est toutes ces attaques
assassines et archi faux
mais il ya une loi qui fait en sorte que
le président doit absolument chrétiens
fac et le web s'est toujours érigé par
les chrétiens mais là les deux états de
population est musulmane ses fesses
comme facteur temps qu'ils veulent pas
faire de recensement genre le douillet
dit qu'on allait de fonder le
recensement parce que la population
musulmane prend toujours plus appeler
toutes les brefs mais brett hawke est
intéressant clientèle que ce gold
pourquoi c'est omar qu'ils doivent aussi
comme tu crucifie ses lives cap
est-ce que tu reviens vite ce n'est pas
sa carrière
galati la page 2010 mines guy sorman
bâton ce forum bac pro logistique
pas de nintendo pour pas qu'il est un
ami mais c'est que tu es bon tu étais
comme j'aurais actuelle footage de la
résurrection du christ ce genre de
céline chante j'aime le steak sur scène
j'aime ça je l'écoutais genre les
dimanches mais poli quotidienne qui vont
moi c'était le premier variété que j'ai
raté ils ont percé dans le tabernacle
parce que c'est promis que j'écoute je
suis pas encarté mais j'écoutais athées
ou quoi la seconde que l'oeil j'ai plus
à cellectis kidjo et l ordre du roi tu
le quittes un ami à moi je veux avoir
ton opinion sur la question de la
laïcité de l'état
bars parce que moi c'est moi c'est une
question sur laquelle chu vraiment
ambivalent parce que d'un côté je me dis
mettons dans mon esprit utopique je me
dis il ya aucune religion qui rien à
voir avec les décisions qui sont prises
pour la société ce c'est comme ça je le
vois tu sais la région aucun lien dans
la société fait de ce côté là la laïcité
de l'état je trouve que c'est positif
parce que ça enlève n'importe quel buzz
autant le christianisme que n'importe
quelle autre religion on les tient mais
de l'autre côté je respecte vraiment la
décision individuelle de suite d'abord
l'artiste vue puis de la deûle à vivre
de la façon avec laquelle tu veux la
vivre en fait pipi ou est ce que on se
place le nord-ouest pacifique les
quelques semaines bonne opinion sur
cfoot moi je vais vous dire merci ça
date de longtemps que je peux monter
gars tu sais qu'il faut il faut pas
confondre lie ce type de loi 21 qui la
loi veil très plat l'ice tea ces deux
choses complètement différentes pour moi
je trouve que la loi 21 définir si c'est
la nouvelle loi qui a passé qu'ils y
mettent qui se posent et rendre le
québec en état laïc qui fait en sorte
que dans la charte des droits et
libertés du québec siq qu'on est un état
laïque puis qu'ils y mettent les signes
religieux partout partout dans l'espace
public en position d'autorité de l'état
sans emploi qui si cela la laïcité ce
concept que je suis totalement d'accord
c'est juste que je trouve pas que ça
sexe
rim à travers la religion des gens qui
travaillent pas dans le sens que 1 et
après tout je veux qu'il soit totalement
laïque mais je trouve que pourra être le
plus laïc possible si plus de religion
possible parce qu'on craint 6e mon
expression dans la east ici peu importe
la religion tout petit enis tête à tête
tu deviendras citoyenneté tu fais partie
de l'état de droit de ta religion parce
que qu'est-ce qui arriva caloy 21,6 que
même si l'intention est donc bien qu'on
veut juste séparée little de l'église
puis comme c'est les résidus de comme ce
travail qu'on a fait depuis la
révolution tranquille de s'affranchir de
l'église je comprends ce ressentiment
je dis juste que ce projet de loi en
tant que tel il discrimine une partie
l'aspect une grande partie dans ce
projet de loi c'est les femmes
musulmanes il femmes voilées vivement
pis si sûrs qu'on attaque le plus puis
je trouve que qu'est ce qui me fait chi
si le non dit encore une fois c'est que
je trouve que ce sentiment vers la
laïcité et des saint gillois parce qu'on
dit que c'est justement pour séparer
l'église plus tôt mais moi ce que
j'observe c'est que beaucoup des études
envers la communauté musulmane d'y
cacher un travail sont molles
puis quand on a deux respecte qu'on dise
pas que c'est un problème cerveau fait
10 au québec puisqu'elle est on le dit
mais 6hif de faire une campagne
électorale comme si le plus gros enjeu
en ce moment au québec si les
infirmières peuvent porter un voile sa
fille ou l'islamophobie salle mène la
discussion
ce projet doit le comment il fait
comment il était passé le bâillon la
clause dérogatoire ça c'est des choses
sont en projet pour les gens qui savent
pas un boyau c'est quand y revenons à
magenta qui fait juste ok on speed
champions fc on voit qu'on veut puis on
vote avec un bouillon une clause de
regard trop dans le projet doit ça fait
en sorte que ça passe
il pourrait par voie de recours au
tribunal jean blaise a va passer au
crible ans après ceux ci sa poche après
un peu plus de challenge il a l'amour
vrai bien sûr avec 6 heures un peu
choquée elle est la façon de le faire si
l'objectif est celui d'avoir un atelier
puis je pense pas que quelqu'un reporter
voile ça affecte ma déception de la
religion ça m'affecte pas du tout je
pense pas que si la preuve d'un enfant
porteur voile je pense pas que ça change
je pense pas que il ya beaucoup de gens
qui vont dire que l'expression de
l'islam dans l'espace public c'est pour
conquérir le monde fait ça depuis à
steve aussi le grand remplacement il
faut utiliser les mots que l'extrême
utilise aussi c'est pas vrai toutes ces
chutes le on y tellement pas beaucoup
québec si tellement une
et smartphones marginalité de la
communauté musulmane qui toutes les becs
qui porte un voile qui travaillent dans
l'espace public aussi on dr fille sexy
tellement absurde dit que le monde voit
pas qu'on puisse y joue pour gagner
intéressant à l'intérieur de leur esprit
nationaliste de fer qui monte au québec
qu'on veuille d'accord et tous mes
shoots en québécois que toi puis ma
moyens pour toi mais c'est porter le
voile à laquelle droit d'être faux king
jugement collet sait plus intelligente
que toi bon jour mais impossible je te
dise ce concert colis ce genre si le
jugement un caractère de quelqu'un pour
faire partie si justement justement dans
l'idée de dire que c'est vraiment une
infime minorité de femmes voilées qui
travaillent dans l'espace public j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
deux personnes blanches qui vont devoir
enlever leurs symboles religieux leur
croix leurs pratiques c'est juste que je
dis que ça affecte plus les favoris
passent contact elle mettra croûtons
chantage pour spéciaux août en grève
symbolique 40 ans mais chic et encore
this parce qu'il ya encore des
classements moi j'ai grandi à chantilly
puis on faisait le notre père à chaque
début de course ce sera l'école primaire
à la veille à vingrau crucifix dans sa
classe et ça mais c'est tout seul sans
va également si c'est pour moi ça c'est
ultra positive mais je comprends que ça
hoekstra 6 une minime partie du monde
qui sont vraiment plus touchés par ce
mais en même temps est-ce qu'on fait la
règle pour une une minime partie du
monde où est-ce qu'on fait la règle pour
enlever tout ce qui amène m marche des
relations fait la règle juste parce que
si ce que le monde ils vont faire
convoquer pour moi qu'à voir
gouvernement sur cette question des
motards grave est au centre de la
discussion c'est ce que je déplore c'est
que la caq s'est fait élire là-dessus
dont on va faire la charte des valeurs
mieux que l'apiculture va se faire élire
voici projet lac silicon valley danser
le rock roll is bras mais je suis
d'accord je suis d'accord avec l'idée
que ça appelle ou à l'électorat qui
veulent justement
que l'islamophobie pipi ces choses là
par contre l'idée derrière reste une
idée que moi je capable d'endosser
mettons aussi piqué qui ont peu j'ai pas
voté pour la can à cause de cela je peux
comprendre que la terrasse que je vois
j'ai l'impression cecchetti justement le
québec des prix révèle sont tranquilles
sans québec osq et l'éclairage est en
position de pouvoir aussi dans les
institutions qui emploie décisionnel
tandis que les crucifix plaindra pas que
tu voudrais tu étais petit et quelqu'un
à la direction de l'école qui édite
chaque élève a offert du rapport au
matin en commençant dans des écoles qui
sont un cas d école qui parler et parler
mais ça absolument
moi j'étais au collège notre-dame sa
communauté
il a beau avec carey price qui habite
encore le pion a pas de crise non mais
c'est moi non plus je trouve que ça ah
bon ça mais thil le sicom c'est la
religion mais ton d'être de ton école
qui était aux primaires est encore dans
l'adn des écoles qui on essaie encore de
telles l'enfoncer un peu des dents dans
gorge tandis qu'elle pas parce que ta
prof à leurs voiles piqué côté aucune
mal à nos clients un pouvoir décisionnel
dans l'organisation du col puis dans le
contenu de tri qui voit pas parce qu'une
prof qui exportent la voile qui est faux
de mettre à l'écart un commentaire ça va
être beau geslin précise parce que
comment comment tu iras dick le problème
qu'on parle d'elles a dit quant aux
incidents dans la fonction publique est
ce que c'est un problème en ce moment
qui fait en sorte que du monde qui
reçoivent pas les services par l'état
qui ont besoin ou qui reçoivent par bon
est-ce que ça chiffre qu'il faut
adresser fondamentalement ou c'est juste
une résolution de steve et moi j'ai pas
l'attachement émotionnel en ou est-ce
qu'elle québec était dans la révolution
portée même si le comprends très bien
c'est quand mathieu bock côté à la
retombée un ferry yachts et dessine moi
j'ai déjà parlé
emotionnellement avait plus parce que je
com - ge en jeu sans aucun problème avec
le fait que le monde ait des signes que
la génération de 10 mettant les gens
sont mes parents mettant mes parents
sont vigoureusement protesté parce que
d'autres leurs parents est très était
très croyant y ont grandi densité québec
le droit puis yeux des yeux des
décrochements pour mes parents la
religion est égale égalitaire dit c'est
l'impression complète avant la
révolution
j'ai l'impression petit mon corps et je
ne sais pas ce que je me trompe intime
et on s'y met ton toi ton attachement ou
au ramada mettons que je dis qu'ils plus
culturelle que religieuse j'ai
l'impression que c'est la même affaire
pour la jeune fille avait quoi ce qui
peut le voir le ton j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'elle fait plus parce que
alain attachement à ses racines de cette
culture le et que sa mère le porte puis
qui s'étend de la pompe piketty comme du
reproduit un peu lisse qui ont été
sauvées et que c'est vraiment plus un
jeu l'impression s'est rendu plus un
symbole culturel qu'un symbole religieux
puisqu'elle fait peur qu'elle fait parce
que elle personnellement l'attachement à
ce truc le plus que pour le symbole at
love qu'est ce qui veut dire pis que
comment il a pu être perçu comme le
comme un moyen de pression ça y est
mieux des dérives avec les religions
tout le temps partout toutes les
religions les femmes et les enfants
le voile est sûrement utiliser pour
apprécier des femmes par an dont c'est
la force et que les rues toutes les
religions on peut prendre justifier sur
les musulmans mais c'est comme toutes
les religions aux fondements ont des
propos forts stop
fucked up qui croyons dire qu'ils disent
tu pas du monde qui veulent pas du monde
de google mais comme les restes us qui
décrit là dedans il ya des chiffres qui
pose pour les mots côte qu'on a en ce
moment fait qu'il ya une version genre
du vingt et unième siècle de l'islam qui
existent que la majorité du monde
pratiquant la grande majorité qui comme
tu dit attaché à des chaînes culturelles
ou des chefs spirituels pour elle son
voile comment que l on lui enseigner
tout
c'est des passages de c'est juste
tellement agressant dans l'espace public
en voile pour certaines personnes c'est
juste pour rire un jour j'aimerais moi
aussi ce qui change
puis-je aussi c'est peut-être ma vision
cynique de lire trop de communes
travaille ma vie deux genres des justes
est ce que c'est la personne qui écrit
c'est parce que on parlait en os et n
ont pas beaucoup de gens qui commandent
des chutes facteur même quand tu auras
mais aussi de gens chaque fois qu'une
nouvelle sur des musulmans qui
commandent des cheats facteurs en est on
a vu des milliers dans ta vie si j'en ai
existe ce trailer c'est l'internet
existait mais il existe mais ça ça
existe des concerts y sont les musulmans
qui sont moins basse québec c'est
l'événement qui m'a le plus choqué on
croise une mosquée depuis pour vrai
agent je peux y avait une grosse trace
parce que moi j'ai eu un groupe qui est
des cahiers guitare il chuta renfort des
québec g batterie parce qu'ils m'ont
fait capoter puis un an plus tard il a
offert à la mosquée en nouvelle-zélande
ce qu'est ce qui est arrivé c'est moi
j'étais vraiment sur un terrain dans ce
temps là puis comme je te limite le
quelques temps sur l'iss mais ce qu'on
me dit aussi dix extrémistes et sean
paul tschaen puis georges family avec
cécile le genre j'essaye de le
comprendre ça fait longtemps plus
acheter là dessus sur une chaîne à lire
le monde tellement il faut qu'ils
remettre des clips j'ai vu tout le clip
oh complète ce sera parfait jouer
semaine puis georges palante
heureusement ce qui les pousse à vaincre
au rassemblement pour la pharma maire
d'uzerche pas là moi ce qui joue juste
si je avec québec qui s'en moquent
genre si juste complètement je n'arrive
pas à expliquer comment sens-tu élu
georges quand c'est arrivé l'an fer avec
la musique en deux ans j'ai fait une
crise de panique après jetée dans le
métro j'ai un paquet d attente aux gens
tout l'enjeu n'est pas parce qu'après
deux jours plus tôt dans le métro où
certains y avait eu un autre attend
juste dans un bouillonnement i7 fallait
que j'aille à l uqam d'attaché dans le
métro american jeté sur sa gorge était
erroné de penser que c'est l'équipe sont
fait qu'un parti politique arrive fait
que son agenda ce soit au moins on est
tellement bon vu tellement là estimé que
moi je sais que ça bosse je comble à
mayenne police en comble non c'est ce
que je sache
ça fait ch mais tribut que lui
je sais pas si je pense pas que des amis
la loi en za les arabes vont pays
excellence qu'est ce que tu fais piquer
ce que je fais au fait je comprends
c'est comme moi je fais du doubs ses
inventions automatique il nuancé
building qui vont aller insulter père
cultive des artistes à cause de certains
qui vont aller plus se radicaliser tu
prends pitié c'est ça c'est une teuf
teuf question mais ce métier ceux ci
comme je pense que ça va passer au
tribunal le tribunal a coécrit moi je
pense que parce qu'avoir gros et veut la
discussion parce qu'en ce moment qu'est
ce qui va arriver
ce ça va être juste ça va remettre en
question de l'autorité du québec de
faire des lois jona de souveraineté dans
le territoire puis en plus faux king
gerry barr est vrai qu'une loi 101 v2
bientôt qui veut et qui parlent fort des
chutes fin octobre en fait je pense que
la discussion tous l'assurent
indiquerait que votre fidèle l'espace de
france il tout faire revenir de l'avant
surtout quand ottawa veut légiférer
genre comme je pense qu'ils vont de
cette loi si facteurs modéré ou d'apport
ces contrats verts s'étaient vus comme
des anglophones l'ouest et messi comme
des racistes avec les français c'est
qu'une fois que vous le site même si je
le rendrai pas le prendre pour du cash
les ont précédés langue d'origine
et il ya la langue le français je pense
que c'est l'armée une chute qui l'a la
laïcité parce que je vois clairement
pourquoi que vous protégez france est
une boîte à québec où j'ai un
attachement profond à la france l'egypte
aux arts loi sans merci
quand applique des lois longtemps intel
c'est impossible d'approcher dhien à
100% il ya des débordements tout il ya
des chiites que tu oublies il ya des
chiffres qui vont aller trop loin et des
gens qui travaillent le faisait langue
française qui ont une vue sûrement trop
express extrémistes qui font de shead
monde sait il ya tout le temps des
expressions dégénérative la protection
allant français je trouve que comme un
généraliste en vue d'une place que je
trouve légitime qu'est ce que je trouve
quand la ftc ne trouve pas que ça ait
une place légitime je pense aussi
transparent a donné un état
gestion des symboles is to be bop même
pas proche lors je pense qu'elle québec
samedi society qui le plus affranchis
justement à cause de cet argent avec
vous la génération justement que après
les boomers se sont fait élever avec
make cette étude fait que je pense qu'on
y côté parce que je n'apprécie vraiment
que ça vient avec comme on disait tantôt
c'est tout là c'est tout la même
génération qui prend des décisions si
c'est si cette génération-là été marqué
par justement le rituel envers la
religion peut possiblement que ça
explique la raison pourquoi tu vois plus
comme un problème de société comme on
peut le voir depuis tant que ce sera pas
justement des gens qui ont grandi comme
et gabri nadeau-dubois que notre hd
grandi avec dans même dans même pensé
mesure que les religions existent comme
pénalement et ingall existe mais j'ai
juste à noël quand quand tu vas grand
marin plat second qui grand-maman être
capable d'y aller et puis personne va à
l'église en fait qui est temps que ce
soit pas ce monde là que l'on attendait
sinon j'imagine que ça va être vu comme
un problème c'est comment grandir dans
un en amérique dans les années 2000
postes les veines
je pense que je peux très bien j'ai un
autre présent ramener sur mon époque je
suis musulman et et lights qui mixait ch
comme non mais tu vas peut venir qu'à
d'origine jusqu'à moi je les vis qui
parce que moi je sais ce qu'ils te
sentais goût de greenock pas si beaucoup
pris l'avion quand j'étais jeune
j'allais souvent au maroc puis en europe
1 puis comme les wendel search
on est quatre dans la famille ce genre
absents mon frère mon père c'est un ou
trois cimetières pouillonnais qui se
fait prendre tout le temps est-ce que
j'attribue ce à poznan eleven peut-être
mais comme fois et c'est que les
aéroports ont changé pour tout le monde
s'il ya des blancs 6 on prendra les
rênes de monsieur sont fait qu au québec
et
j'ai pas pour les 26 ars de quoi moi je
peux comparer avec un vin parce que
c'est un signe pour trois mois a fait
que c'est seulement dans quelques heures
seulement que je me rappelle que je suis
ici j'ai raconté ça j'étais dans sa
liste potentielle que le volume 1 dans
la salle hugot on était soit dès lundi
prochain
non mais je vais être très bon même
mais non mais parce que je trouve qu est
ce que je dis sur les candidats et
fucked up
des fois j'ai mangé instrumentaliste les
médias sociaux des fois et fucked up et
cette année ça a dégénéré gens avec
charge en quinze jours moi je trouve à
chaque fois que j'aurai public sur le
avant que ça prenne des proportions
démesurées 8 mai mais ouais mais c'est
ce qu'ont tenté que là dessus parce que
c'est la lime c'est devenu trop si
nécessaire parti qui est drôle c'est
même moi j'ai fait des ddd super bolide
en lui des genres est un leader qui a
décoré pas d'écouteurs lol si la ccsa la
masculine des taxes et le personnage
oui mais je compte voir c'est pas seul
point les sépare seul point l'inter ce
qu'on a vu à tv je dis moi je pense que
l'instabilité sur charvaux aussi
beaucoup sur des masses qui remonte à
chaud propos qu'on l'ait midi puis six
comme à majorque dans leurs meetings
sont dit qu'on monte à l'air un peu trop
genre il ya des gens il ya des gens
soient choqués mai prochain si je prends
ce show vraiment qui est un peu chiant
que la production et ses claques mort
qui se finit en baisse à quel point ce
serait comme que gérer le juge est une
bonne formule est ce qu au québec soit
six facteurs soit 6 genre commun qui
devrait impacter la vie de ce galop pour
toujours en maître en faisant sait plus
ce qu'est ce que moi je pourrais jamais
faire
je le trouve qu'à trouver ménages
j'écoute au daily star academy jeu beach
dans mon salon comme n'importe quel bon
consommateur des télévisions le tissu
c'est fait c'est fait pour ça mais après
cinq ans d'absence et des réseaux
sociaux est en fait une espèce
d'affaires justement le débat des deux
métiers hamonistes est carrément la
cyberintimidation plus vague déjà avec
le petit combo fort sur charles si comme
cela qui plaît c'est comme non les
pervers narcissique mérite qu'ils
utilisent le diagnostic permanence et
qu'à cause de ce que tu vu à tv à
travers le prisme du montage des
menottes extrapole apparaissent et se
déconstruit cette saison dont des chars
eu beaucoup d'influencé comme chez épi
tout comment cette saison s'est passé
par son emprise sur les garçons des
bughes il aurait vraiment dit le poteau
puis sur syfy le cfi leur blabla on
s'arrange pas
on y est préparé notre gueule elle fait
ainsi que - charles s'était pas juste
que je voulais qu'ils y étaient une
fluidité comme avant même qu'ils
n'aiment pas j'ai fait un bide aux
données s'appelle just wait en duo des
cheveux ça chaque année j'ai pas marie
de charles juste parce que je l'aï
oublié temps en temps je fais comme je
m'aime pas j'avais 30 ans d'histoire de
son exercice était de rigueur
c'était très clair dans le sens c'est
peut-être un quart mais en ce moment moi
je chapeaute que j'ai toutes les
informations pour dire faucheurs que
tonga le match parce que tu peux parler
du personnage justice pas que ça bleed
dans quelque chose que tu ses potes
encore de ces 10 commentaires sur
l'émission mettez la personne chargea
connaît pas déjà rencontrés çà serait
deviendrez je trouverais naissance à mon
ami peut-être pour prend peut-être parce
que la préméditation sont pas crédibles
on est quand même quelque chose d
spécial qu'elle a toutes les gauches
sont sortis d'odeillo tout dit ah ben il
était quand même utile puis genre y
avait une influence positive tout les
gold technologie soi dans un show télé
réalité 2 sortes et la star ac' la
maison au quartier bien des doutes qui
reçoit des menaces chaque jour à coups
de milly c'est surtout savoir comment
j'ai un ami qui lui nous a dit et elle
est tellement qu'oracle chiens et des
banques grecques dans le détail des
faits que c'est comme ça très beau dire
dans mon vidéo je dois dans le vide ou
qu'il y ait d'autres individus autre
chose qu'un pas qui je suis au début
cette vidéo est pour parler du
personnage que charles a accepté de
jouer jeudi mais pour moi c'est comme
c'est juste drôle et il y avait des
enfants aux tweets juste brûler la table
d'élimination là avec qui a ri qui dans
son montage pause qu'ils sont des vrais
par tout ce qui t'arrive est une victime
des ben ali
oui je compte ouvrir fcz et vidéo le
questeur et fait une vidéo sur moi des
bayous j'ai un titre en coupe uefa king
plate je m'intéressais pas c'est chaque
fois qu'on parlait de vous jeter comme à
autre chose
parlez-moi de joannie sandri qu il est
alors que je pense que c'est le
sentiment partagé gilet jaune et cédric
jeauneau ce test ainsi si comme la
première vidéo sur ma chaîne béton qui
est assez drôle on va parler de ceux ci
dans la première vidéo sur ma chaîne
comme fête des vieux enfants j'avais une
chaîne youtube a comme si je venais à la
crise 5 septembre
j'avais mis une demi avant jc des vidéos
facebook je l'avais milieu elle avait
fait comme 14 use plus j'ai pris votre
heure de vérité
je découpe et pour partie comme ç'avait
été genre une autre heure de vertiges et
prix lipp ce budget photomontage drôle
j'ai cette vidéo fait onze mille j'avais
fait dans ce montage et j'avais fait
comme si tu étais mad compte adamo qui a
gagné parce que lui était pas vraiment
un amour avec c'est ce que tu es
tellement quand adam o'callaghan et non
pas du tout maintenant je t'aimais je
t'aime à d'avoir perdu mais pop au
contraire d'un mode avoir gagné perdu un
gros minet ce que vous avez perçu que tu
es rendu un gros ni madame encore vous
étiez dans le jus non pas du tout mais
nous autres tout moment parce que
j'estime en gagner un
on était les finalistes qu'on avait
écouté les émissions natal c'est sûr que
c'est sur ce nouveau studio
si vous aviez passé à cette saison je
pense que le monde
et puis il ya messi a pas aimé des
coupes tout mais je trouve qu'ils ont
valu plus ceux ci est des vrais couples
qui se forment quand c'est comme la
foire qui limite vincent et annick et el
chico tse qui ont habité ensemble de la
saison le c'est bien plus facile de
croire en l'amour quand c'est qu'ils ont
passé 24 7 pendant deux semaines qu'ils
connaissent mais quand on pense que vous
parlais juste 15 minutes à chaque quatre
jours c'est comme quand même je trouve
suspect au 10 bis ce genre de vol aux
vans et les voyages ça se passe des 24
heures sur 24 sauf si celle ci survient
un voyage qui était quand même là vous
dire c'est pas mal
ces facteurs je vais te faire des
commentaires oui la baleine je vaux je
vais peut-être enfin un renouvellement
j'ai pas vu le vent je vais leur écoute
et je vais l'écouter avant deux fois
avant de regarder la saison mais je
pense moi j'aime la télé réalité
nouvelle liste est une chose que j'aime
de folie culturel québécois qui j'aime
la télé réalité
j'aime les gens de 20 à 30 ans à la
télévision parce que c'est sur le
casting qui ont fait ce choix
j'aime la télé en plus c'est un si
j'écoutais la ville et des coeurs brisés
en france ceci si audi annexe l'avoir vu
des clips de ce que on pourrait jamais
atteindre ce niveau divertissement mais
vu que c'est possible comme moi je suis
un attachement profond au contenu
québécois je trouve à auby mais la ville
d'accueil crise et c'est quelque chose
dont on ne pourrait pas avoir su au
québec on pouvait pas pourquoi parce
qu'elle négocie ouvertement ni trop tu
ne pourrais pas été de trop de trucs on
a exposé genre sans trembler c'est des
trucs du genre à assumer leur les gars
font des moves comme khaled a fait le
pij à personne dit rien puis monte
encore lu ce livre c'est comme le gars
il ya parlé pendant 15 minutes avec la
fille d'un autre prétendant qu'ils
arrivent puis comme commandes soit par à
l'autre lyon vient de parler tu me dit
avait refilé la possession du match nice
marque française mène au québec lors n'y
en a plus
ou est-ce que les gens qui les suivent
casio le ch vous vous êtes des gros
secteurs de podcasts les gens qui
écoutent sans fil avec moi pas tu as
fait divers partout il ya des podcasts
un pitch on parce que les émissions sont
l'être dav ans puis on va a été vu tout
le monde dans la culture québécoise pas
de la culture politique dans le spectre
politique partout je parle plus de gens
possible c'est que cela te lire
le demain à nîmes mardi demain je trouve
avec vittorio charlton j'ai fait une
avait ici charlie justement et les
autres si secret il y en a une très
grosse qui sont obligés autres piétons
dans ce cul je te coupe le maintenant
dans un monde de ski et déjà énormément
podcast le qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont pas de
casse il fait différent que l'eepad
qu'est ce qu'on s'en soit pris en charge
je trouve que j'ai une capacité à
ramener les gens au niveau ce que c'est
comme si je trouve que je les fait même
la belgique ou du coup votre podium
on parle à un niveau très méthode des
choses parce qu'il ya beaucoup de codes
qu'on met dans la discussion que moi
j'enlève dès le début par comment moi je
parle ça rend la personne à la haye ce
que je trouve que ce regard de mes
entrevues que les gens ont fait je pense
pas que d'aussi bonne entrevue de ses
joueurs sur internet en fait je pense
que je suis là podcasts ou sky one on
one avec une personne de la même
entrevue au québec genre je pense qu'il
ya eu un peu a dit jean à 10,7 convolait
respect écouté dans des cours
universitaires sur la diversité dans les
médias optiques profil utilisés chaque
année
comme je veux juste en face à sigean moi
c'est vraiment la one - joe hogan by by
just vraiment évident à être connue pour
qu'il ya de tout le spectre politique
tous les spectres culturels puissent se
loger au début j'ai pour que ça soit six
classes et c'est ce qui est 6e quand je
vais être prêt intellectuellement
mathieu beaucoup tu veux bien qu'on me
le pardonne événements let's go et 1
semaine fait savoir m non merci de
m'avoir invité
je voulais pas ça fait longtemps mais je
conçois live jeudi sa tombe bien mais ça
tombe bien les célèbres et bien des
choses juste fait une belle impression
ce que je ne suis pas un moment donné se
maintenir en bonne chance que moi j'ai
vraiment aimé ce qui fait quand vous
allez parler
on a parlé de tout ce qui les fait merci
d'avoir écouté ses podcasts jusqu'à la
fin j'espère que vous avez apprécié la
conversation ça prouve que vous êtes de
réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de casser on vous remercie
vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe il ya surper tués a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pga mais on fait aussi
des encore moins de filtres qui sont
exclusifs aux membres et urnes puisque
on parle d'homme n'est que l'émoi de la
conversation convient d'avoir ce qu'on
met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets qu'on voulait aborder ou
qu'on abordés pendant le podcast donc
allez sur notre page culturelle et le
lien vers sa voix dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin